all right hello
everybody
so i hope everybody's doing okay
i'm happy to see that jacob is there
jacob russell who i haven't seen in a
while in the uh in the chat so that's
pretty cool
um i just wanted to a few things before
we start i turned off the super chats
and uh the reason why i turned off the
super chats it's just because they're
just too many questions and uh
people that i people that i trust told
me that you that towards the end when i
end up answering the super chats often
i answer very uh
very short answers let's say
or i just tell people that they're not
allowed to ask you that question so um
so i turned out the super chat i i when
i logged on i saw that some people had
already put some in
and so i'll look at those and try to
answer them
uh despite that
but uh so yeah so that's what we're
gonna do and just also
just because these q a's are becoming
just unmanageable next month is going to
be a little different and so even even
with the people who um
who are uh
are kind of supporting me monthly and
putting in questions i'm gonna have to
i'm gonna have to have someone go
through and pick
the top questions also well on the one
hand because
it's just too much and and you've seen
it i ran out i kind of
my
my um
response has become less interesting
let's say it seems as the super as the
conversation goes on and also
the other problem is that there are some
questions that she comment keep coming
up almost in every q a
and so for the sake of everybody who's
been following what i'm doing i'm we're
going to try to yeah we're going to try
to focus on those that haven't been
asked the best questions um
and so yeah so i'm gonna have
i'm going to have uh lisa you guys have
seen lisa in the um
in the chat once in a while i don't know
if she's there today but you're but lisa
is going to go over the questions and
pick the um
the best ones and so
so people have to be nice to lisa
because she's the one who's going to
pick the questions
all right so here we go so i'm going to
start are there some announcements yes
there are some amazing announcements so
um
despite the predictions of symbolic
memes the uh god's dog the last page was
penciled two days ago and so it's it's
officially the entire story is is just
needs to be now colored and inked which
means that the crowdfunding for god's
dog is going to start
as soon as we can kind of gather
everything together i'm making a video
we're going to decide of the different
tiers
and so we're going to start the
crowdfunding very soon and um i'm really
excited about it because
you know this this book obviously took a
very long time to make this uh
the uh the graphic novel but it really
is just the first book it's not the
whole story uh we're doing it very
lusciously with a lot of illustrations
it's there's a lot of breathing in the
book you know the taking time to get to
show uh to show the the action
and so
it's really going to be a series of book
and what i want is to really knock this
crowdfunding out of the park so that
cord nielsen the artist can quit his job
and just do this full-time so that we
can put out books you know twice a year
or something like that try to get those
books out to you so that we can really
kind of tell this story in an epic
fashion
um so that is what's going on and it's
it's pretty exciting i've already had
some some international publishers uh
people from eastern europe contact me
and asked me if i wanted to maybe
publish with them
but uh at least for the english version
i really want to go with crowdfunding
just because
i like the idea of being in control and
i like the idea of people getting
involved because we're also going to
produce a book called god's dogs secrets
which is going to contain uh some of my
original drawings that i did 10 years
ago of saint of uh saint christopher and
saint george you know and all the
different uh saints that appear in the
story but also there's going to be an
article written by matsir on the
symbolism of samson and so it's probably
going to officially be the first thing
he's published since
uh since the language of creation so all
of that is just really i'm just really
excited about all of it and uh so yeah
so so uh so that those are the
announcements that i
have to make another thing that's
happening is
i'm going to be on jordan peterson's
channel with
john viveki and bishop baron that was
already recorded it was very interesting
to uh to get that
put together and so i don't know when
jordan's putting it out but another
interesting thing that seems to be
happening is that i did a conference for
the the union society of montreal the
montreal jung society
and i didn't talk about jung but you
guys know that i wouldn't talk about
jung but i uh
i talked about some things that i never
talked about before and surprise
surprise jordan peterson appeared in the
public and so he was there in the zoom
call i could see his wife and and then i
could see tammy and then jordan appeared
um
and so jordan really liked the talk that
i gave and he wants to put it on his
channel as a continuation
of his
own bible series so that's pretty
exciting because i um anyways so i i was
able to talk about it in a way that i
haven't been able to uh to talk about
that uh yes
so um all right so let's go let's do
this i'm going to start with the uh the
website
and uh here we go
um
so someone in the chat billy a asks can
you please talk about why you would not
talk about jung well partly it's because
i don't really know about jung that much
there's something about him that makes
that makes me less interested in him
because
uh
i i think the psychologization of the of
symbolism is something which is good but
it's also limited because if you notice
a difference i really talk about
symbolism as a cosmic structure and so
that is one of the uh that is one of the
issues with jung um
and also he just jung just makes
mistakes in some of his symbolic
interpretations
in terms of seeing evil as a as a almost
like a positive force uh the idea of
seeing um
satan and and christ as uh as brothers
like all this kind of stuff means that
he really didn't understand some
christian symbolism well enough in my
opinion but you know get
get what you can from where you can get
it that's what i always say and so if
young whatever it is that jung says
which is interesting and true then it's
it's worth you know it's worth knowing
but um all right so here we go let's
start josh the mover ask what's the deal
with all the ostensibly non-christian
celebrities claiming to have sold their
souls to the devil
is this like a new thing i don't think i
followed this
how is it that are celebrities saying
they sold their soul to the devil
um so i don't know i don't know what
phenomena you're referring to i haven't
noticed that people are saying that if
they are it's not totally surprising um
you know
uh so yeah i don't know i mean did they
have they've done it in a in a kind of
colloquial way where they basically say
that they sacrificed
uh
they sacrificed what's most precious to
be famous maybe you know do they mean it
more specifically that is that they
they did some kind of ritual or some
kind of contract where they sold their
soul to the devil uh then i i don't know
i mean maybe it's possible a lot of
people are crazy
um
all right okay so uh kingsley says can
you provide some insight into sukkot the
feast of tabernacles one of the three
major feasts of
israel
the
christian church celebrates the other
two major feasts of pascha christ's
resurrection and pentecost the coming of
the holy spirit in the calendar but not
explicitly uh sukkot uh
actually it's my understanding that we
do celebrate uh we do celebrate sukkot
in a way
um
it's the transfiguration there's there's
a relationship between
between the the
the transfiguration and the feast of
tabernacles the feast of tents you know
and it has to do
it it has to do with
to be totally honest like i don't
completely understand it like i don't
completely understand it it seems it's
related because you can see that christ
is
that christ it that the the disciples
say we want to build tents for moses and
uh and elijah and christ says
no
and then christ then they are covered
with the glory of god and so it has
something to do with that it has
something to do
with
a
a filling up of everything you know with
the glory of god you know
kind of the idea that in a way we don't
need
the tents anymore something like that
but i i have to admit that although i
can see that there's a relationship
between the feasts of tabernacles and
the transfiguration
i don't totally understand it so i mean
just one more thing for me to think
about because obviously it's there in
the story and it's there in the text but
i don't totally get it
um
all right okay
so king of the rat kings asks you your
thoughts related to enoch often bring
lovecraft to mind do you have any
thoughts on his work or if you've read
it on the king in yellow by robert
chambers
now i haven't read lovecraft
um
i know a little bit about his kind of
lore but i haven't read him and i keep
telling myself i should read lovecraft
just because everybody tells me that i
should but i haven't i haven't read
lovecraft
um
i mean for sure the idea of the cosmic
monster is something which i think is
interesting the idea of the break-in of
the cosmic monster i think is something
which which is interesting especially
now
it's as if this idea that that these
that the kazakh monsters will break into
a world that wasn't ready for them or
that didn't even think they exist or
had ignored their existence i think it's
something which is resonant with what is
going on right now which is you know the
kind of
break-in of religion that that's
returning you know in a wild and kind of
crazy way this
this this kind of possession which is
happening with people people being
possessed by
um
in a kind of hysteria a social hysteria
that you can see related to social
justice or that you can see related to
even in terms of the pandemic right you
see a strange kind of hysteria that is
that is going on
um
and so i think that uh yeah so i think
that that it's pro it is probably
related but i would need to look into
lovecraft more
so ivan buaven says if an election can
can be seen as inducing a mini
revolution in order to inoculate a
national body against a larger
revolution
could it still be said to be a
functional vaccine if the mini
revolution produces no
discernible effect
um
i don't know i mean i i really i do kind
of like your idea i like the idea of of
a mini revolution which inoculates
against
a larger revolution so kind of having a
type of controlled change you could say
right a you know a kind of cyclical
change which is contained in a pattern
so that it doesn't go and become out of
control
um
and so
you know it probably the the idea is
that at some point uh
you could say this way at some point
democracy ceases to function by its very
by its very mechanisms you know and
plato saw that right at the outset and
so i think that that's usually you know
it's rather than asking if it can still
be a functional vaccine if the mini
revolution produces no discernible
effect the question would rather be why
is it that at some point
democracies cease to produce
the effect of stabilizing society and
tend to move towards a breakdown and a
polarization and then ultimately
a call for tyranny right a call because
that's how plato saw it plato saw it
basically
you know that it's not it's not just
that a tyrant comes in and takes over
it's at at some point people
people desire the tyrant people want
control and it's something it's
interesting like i remember seeing this
i think that if you're looking at what's
going on right now you can see that
that's actually it's already what's
there
people want this like
i look in uh here in canada you know all
these measures all the the pandemic
measures have
have uh have approval have majority
approval of the population and so
yeah
it seems people are tired of
yeah so
okay roxanne says well i agree and lam
and lament that passive subjection to
entertainment is widespread would you
agree that admiration is a kind of
participation for example if i go out on
a clear dark night to look at the stars
don't i participate by being awed by
god's creation and isn't admiration
deepened through knowledge and through
engaging in admiration with like-minded
friends
for example i can learn to identify
constellations know their stories also
learn about special mechanics applying
this idea to concerts complicates it
thank you for your insights um
and so it's interesting because i agree
that admiration is a form of
participation
but
it's interesting that
so in a normal world like in a
traditional world
you admire
uh valorous people you admire people
that have virtues people who have valor
people who
showed you know either great leadership
or great great uh accomplishment in the
spiritual realm or
in some kind of uh physical realm
uh but the world what the world of
entertainment does is that we end up
admiring we end up having admiration for
clowns
it's like if people admire actors
what the hell like why would you admire
actors like actors
basically spend their time pretending to
be other people
and it's actually really interesting to
see how
people get duped it's like they're
they're getting duped because they're
confusing the actors for the roles that
they play
and then they admire the actors
and uh and so it's the same with these
rock musician types you know where we're
basically admiring
clowns and and uh and jesters
so
that's the issue with entertainment is
that in its very structure if you make
it the center so you could the thing is
it's funny because
you could admire a court jester for
being a really good coach court jester
and i think that that's
that's totally fine right and admire an
actor for being a good actor but when it
entertainment becomes the center of your
your society then you have actors
telling people their political opinions
on making videos about who to vote for
and you know telling us that we need to
get involved in this or that social
social uh
uh you know so this or that social uh
cause or whatever and then it just
becomes completely insane but i think
people you can see that people are
getting tired of that you know all those
stupid videos that came out during the
elections and
watching
uh celebrities virtue signal about covid
and everything there's a little bit of
people are realizing that that this is
not
this is not working you know and so um
so hopefully it'll be a
a reason to change towards admiring more
more participation participative people
people who really participate in the
transformation of our culture
um you know like admiring
it's funny because it's really
interesting it's so funny if you look at
uh look at look at the the the way it's
set up like
people admire actors but nobody admires
screenwriters
people admire singers but nobody admires
songwriters why
i mean this is where you can see how
it's completely upside down because
at least to admire the person who wrote
the screenplay
right at least to admire the person who
who with great art was able to weave
together you know all these these
threads and the same like at least
admire the person who writes songs but
we would we're we would rather admire
the performer you know and if he's if he
writes his songs that's great but he
doesn't even have to if he's just a
performer that's where that's the person
that we
end up admiring more than anybody else
so
uh so frederick says might not the
internet be the [ __ ] of babylon it
looks like an emergent host an upside
down grill maybe into which we pour all
our desires it kind of feels like a
man-made demonic being spirit without a
body
um
and so i agree that there's a there's a
connect there's a connection between the
internet and the [ __ ] but we have to be
careful not to say the horror as
like how can i say this as a
as a specific thing
the [ __ ] is a pattern of being
and the internet can participate in its
pattern but let's say in the internet
you have both the [ __ ] of babylon and
the beast in revelation
so in the very structure of the internet
you have all the possibilities of the
chaos the mixture you know the passions
all of this stuff the trading all of the
things which describe the [ __ ] and then
you also have the possibility of the
absolute clampdown of absolute control
of surveillance of tracking all of this
is also made possible by the internet so
the internet it will rather be a locus
like an extreme locus of where the
relationship between the [ __ ] and the
beast play out this is rather the
pattern of being i keep telling myself i
need to make a video just on that which
is this change that you see in
revelation between
the [ __ ] writing on this complex on
this complex and very
powerful system but then at some point
the beast kills the [ __ ] and then
tyranny ensues but i think i mentioned
it a few times in other videos so yeah
so david flores says in genesis 47 15 20
due to a famine in the land the people
give goods to joseph in exchange for
bread it begins with gold and cattle
than their bodies
and their land in reading this it struck
as strange as i've seen the more
heavenly items mana or seed come down
from above and earthly items flesh or
crops offered upward from below could
you elaborate the meaning of this
pattern of heavenly earthly items all
being offered
from below
so
okay
so this is super important like this
pattern is super important because
joseph is ex is giving is giving grain
if that's my understanding is he giving
br grain or is he giving bread i think
he's giving grain and even if he's
giving bread you kind of have i think
you got to have to understand it as
as grain even if it's bread it's it's
it's that like a transformed version of
the grain
uh and so then people
give that's then you have people giving
from below
to be able to re to to stay alive
from above and what's important in
understanding the story of of joseph is
that there's something you know it's
funny because people always i always
tell people that the bible characters
have two sides all the bible character
characters have a dark a dark side to
them and this is better to understand it
that way because if we want to look
at the bible characters as just being
models for us we're going to run into a
wall pretty fast because none of them
really are completely but there always
is joseph which people always think see
that joseph is you know there's
something about joseph which is hard to
see
you know where he totally does wrong
he's the victim you know he gets taken
uh to um he gets taken to egypt uh
but joseph is something like the man who
is too good
and so
you can see how him being good and him
being heavenly and him not being able to
be tempted
to be tempted let's say from below when
you see him uh
fleeing from potiphar's wife you know
and being willing to leave his garment
in order to
to kind of
pure stay pure
and and stay in the garden you could say
when he leaves his garment with party
far's right leaves his garment with her
it's almost like he's going into the
garden right so there's this idea that
joseph is this
is this pure but then he's he only
becomes too pure and he has an excess of
order so if you want to understand
like a secret in that story is
is that
the way that joseph saved egypt
gave ultimate power to the pharaoh
because everybody traded all their land
and centralized power in the pharaoh
by the manner in which joseph
saved egypt
and
because he did that
that's why the pharaoh could enslave the
israelites
was because he had handed over
total central power to the pharaoh by in
the manner in which he saved uh he saved
egypt
and so
there's the bible is a very powerfully
you know very powerful pattern it's
if you if you pay attention it does it's
never made explicit but if you look at
actions and consequences of actions and
you kind of see it follow through
you know there's all this subtext which
is very very powerful and the idea that
all the egyptians were giving up their
their their their stuff and then
ultimately when they give their land
then they centralize the power of egypt
and a centralized power
is able to treat its strangers you know
with uh with uh yeah
by enslaving them
so i mean i love joseph you know he's
great but it's just good to see how how
how the bible works all right so douglas
matthew says hi jonathan thanks for
still doing these q and a's
all right and so on a previous q a you
said you don't think that the
procedure is the mark of the beast but
seems to be moving in that direction
assuming this that this that
that is still your position let's say
that it does eventually get there
what what would that mean for people who
already partook in it before it was
either revealed
to be or became the mark itself can the
future affect the past in such a way
that it would have been the mark all
along or would it depend too much on the
particulars to answer that so i think
you have to be really careful again you
know what
you have to be really careful about this
kind of stuff because i describe
i'm described i describe patterns to you
and i describe how they kind of manifest
themselves in the world and
we have to not fall in like a strange
legalistic world where
you get trapped
in something and then because you did
something then
you know it's all about transformation
of the person and so
the question of being faced with the
mark
is a question of having to
compromise the most important thing
compromise your faith in god compromise
compromise your faith in christ for a
another
good which is the participation in
society and so until
that happens
it is it is just
it's just fluffy it's just it it doesn't
mean anything to say that this is the
mark or that is the mark if you're
looking for the just the the gesture or
interpreting it in a kind of very
precise way where you're looking tit for
tat to see what event maps on to another
event that's never the way that i talk
anyways i don't talk that way i'm not
saying it's not going to happen it will
happen and it has happened in the past
where people were
were forced to sacrifice their their
faith for
some some worldly good and in the case
of the mark of the beast it's
all worldly good basically participation
in society itself versus
your affiliation to the divine logos and
so
and so what you can see and what's going
on right now is that
a good example is like the the passports
okay and so
in a place where the passports become
necessary for you to actually go to
church
like we're moving close to what this is
about right
in in a in a in a place where
the passport will be associated to
political ideology
that is
that you cannot be receive the passport
if you don't uh
concur
if you can be canceled
politically or spiritually
by you not having the passport to be
able to participate in society
because it's going to go beyond the the
procedure it has more to do the mark
part has more to do with the idea of
tracking and absolute control and
absolute calculation
than the medical procedure okay it's
very important to understand that now
the fact that it comes through a medical
procedure that is like a little that is
you know that's like an instead that's
an injection that has to do with marking
you or whatever in a certain way i mean
it's possible that it's going to play
out that way but i would be careful not
to be too um
how can i say this not to try to map
events onto each other too much you know
when you're when you're doing this but
actually try to understand what it means
and then when it when you understand
what it means then you're going to be
able to identify it when the pattern
manifests itself uh so hopefully that
makes sense and i'm not being too vague
i'm actually trying to avoid certain
words
so that i don't get
booted off
the platform
okay so curacao and curiouser asks is
there a relationship between the scrolls
of the apostles and the icons of
pentecost
and the head coverings in 1 corinthians
11.
in a manuscript of the gospels from the
6th century byzantine there's an image
of mary speaking between the apostles
with their veil paralleling the dome of
heaven above them
standing on rough a translucent sapphire
earth
in more common depictions today i see
the glorified cosmos under the apostle
gathering their words in a single
garment
could the tongues of fire on their heads
represent the glory of god and their
testimony of jesus the glory of man
so
it has to do it does to a certain extent
you could say have to do with glory it
has to do
but it it has to do with uh
this it has to do with multiplication
that's what it has to do and so you can
understand that
the the tongues of fire we we want to
represent them
they receive tongues of fire that is
when they spoke
they spoke in all the languages they
received a
tongue
of multiplication
a tongue of multiplication which can
which can move out into the world and
express the gospel in a way that is
understandable to all peoples in the
entire world
and so that is what ultimately the idea
of uh
the idea of the tongues of fire
represent what they are that's just what
they are that's what tongues of fire are
and so whether or not it manifested
itself as some kind of vision of
something above their heads like it
doesn't seem to say that uh
in in scripture but uh but it's okay
it's great to represent it that way i
think it's important because it it
really is a visual representation of
this this fire which comes down from
heaven right so it's like you can see it
in the icon you have this fire it's like
this fire coming down from heaven and
spreading through the apostles uh out
until the ends of the world
uh and so there's a subtle version of
that which is the actual
fire the actual capacity
to
spread the word and manifest the logos
and fill the world with logos and then
there's the doing of it and the results
of it which are the specific traditions
or specific embodiments
of that happening so it's like
it's it's the actual liturgies in in
slavonic or the bible translated in
different languages or the saints you
know the
the commemoration of the saints of all
these different lands of all these this
multiplicity kind of having a concrete
uh
realization right so you so you have the
active part so think about it exactly
like i explained the icon of christ so
you have christ's blessing with his
right hand and then he's holding a book
in his left hand the blessing is the
capacity to affect the world directly
right the capacity to to to to bless to
curse to to heal to do all these things
and then the book is the result of that
in the world
through
all the all the memories of that all the
the the writings all the liturgy all the
art all you know
the remembering of your name in the book
of life all of these things are the
result of the active part so think of
the icon of pentecost that way right so
you have the active part with the fire
and then you have the passive part or
the receptive part or the manifested
part in the cosmos itself in the world
as it reaches its fullness
um i hope that makes sense man this
stuff is hard to to talk about because
it's uh
yeah
so that makes sense but i don't see a
relationship between the veil i'm i'm
afraid not there's a the
the veil that is uh
the way that it's represented the icon
of pentecost is is more like uh
it's kind of like a container right it's
it's this it's this cloth which holds uh
rather than
the idea of of the higher veil you could
say there's a relationship between the
lower veil and the higher veil just like
there's a relationship between the lower
waters and the higher waters but uh that
is
that is uh that is not one i'm not gonna
go into that here you can find other
places where i've talked about that
um so plumage asks what insight can we
draw from ruth and esther for these
times of hours ruth of course is the
foreign woman who attaches itself to the
people of god and becomes the ancestor
of christ while esther being already a
part
a part of the people of god attached
herself to the foreigner and becomes
queen of the foreign kingdom in order to
save her people
these happen to both of them during
upside down and carnival periods what
can we glean from them yes your insight
is very good this you're yeah i like
your insight
uh you're right ruth and esther are on
the are on the one hand
the end of two stories
and they are
in another way they are also kind of two
visions of the same reality right which
is reaching the end of the world and
when possibilities are finished and
and the carnival and the joining of the
the relationship between joy and the
foreigner to receive new potential you
know and so
this is definitely what is going on here
and so you could say that
what ruth and esther show are
are two ways in which this can happen
and if you look at the story you'll see
that it's very much two opposite ways
in the story of ruth
there's the idea of
what kind of stranger
can join
your
world
in order to increase it
what kind of strange can join your world
in order to increase it and you'll see
that ruth says to her mother-in-law
you know she says your god will be my
god
that's about it
right if you can if you could understand
that
that that's how
so the idea is
for the strange and for the strange to
be properly joined to you
the this strange element has to
recognize the same
transcendent thing
so that you're bound together right so
that's why you have immigrants say the
pledge of allegiance that's why you have
you know
you could imagine it like the idea of
asking the the the jews to come to to
your you know different kings would ask
the jews to come
and they would become vassals directly
to the king but they had to be vassal to
the king or else they wouldn't be they
wouldn't be accepted in
these in the in the ancient nations so
that's the virgin of uh of ruth
and then the virgin the virgin of esther
is
something else it has more to do
it has more to do with the hidden seed
and the and what mature uh has explained
so well and what i've referred to many
times which is the double flip the
double inversion of how when the world
becomes upside down
the seed is hidden
and the seed can operate another
in order for the world to start again
there you have to operate another
another flip right you see that in the
story of elijah as well
uh but the story of esther is the
ultimate
version of that um
and so yes these this type of wisdom is
one we need to pay attention to
especially as
christianity starts to
be eclipsed in the social sphere
you know people will become christians
will become something like esther will
become something like elijah and so
we need to be ready for that and we need
to kind of understand
uh
how this can play out let's say
all right
think of esther
think of esther as as as something like
constantine's mother let's say
it's a good way to understand it uh you
know how this these things happen and
how the strange
through the feminine can bring about
it's not the strange in this ver now
it's the it's the actual seed it's the
thing that's going to to bring life to
the to to
to the world and kind of save things um
all right okay enough of that
and you guys bring me to say things that
i don't want to talk about all right
here you go you you flesh sim world i
don't know what that means i don't know
it's a strange name
uh what is the concept behind theosis
what does it take to become like god in
terms of my required actions what
exactly is it that i'm supposed to
imitate or become
like can you elaborate on that a little
bit more i guess i need something like a
manual
uh thanks very much for your work god
bless you and your family so i mean
definitely if you see it as a manual
you're gonna be in trouble uh
and so we say that
we become god or theosis happens through
participation in god so what what is
that what does that mean
um
and so
the idea of knowledge in the christian
world
is not is participative knowledge
right you when you know something you
somehow you you you have to join with it
to a certain extent
there's a there's a kind of penetration
that happens and it
obviously the ultimate version of that
is a sexual union but there's little
versions of that
um
and so
this is what
this is
this is what it means to be
divinized which is that
if you read the the for example read
sangre of niece's life of moses you'll
get a sense of what that is and so you
have to
you have to do there's two gestures once
you have to look up towards the mountain
towards the top of the mountain where
god where the highest place where the
glory of god kind of comes into the
world so you have to have
christ as a model and you have to attend
to god which means praying which means
worshiping which means
all that stuff
you have to eliminate
you have to break away from the lower
things that attach you to the world and
so all your passions all your desires
all these things that pull you in all
these different directions you have to
kind of be able to detach yourself from
that not because they're bad but because
they enslave us and so that's the
movement you see in the ascetic practice
is to detach yourself from these
passions these things pulling you apart
and then also cohere in love so love god
love your neighbor
move up in that
uh
into god so it's like there isn't uh
the manual is just what jesus basically
said of course it's it's extrapolated
you can read the works of the christian
mystics you can read uh the
the uh the philocalia but the concept
behind theosis is that christianity is a
non-dual proposition
chris god is not we are not outside god
god is god did not god is infinite god
contains all things and all things
proceed from him and return to him
and
there is no outside god and so
it doesn't mean that we're all god in a
weird pantheistic sense it means that we
get our life from god our life is in god
and we and and as we move closer to the
life
of god we have in us then we become more
of who we are and we also become more in
the image of god and ultimately you can
phrase it to say that we participate in
god and we become god through
participation
so that's the concept behind it
hopefully that's understandable
so arosa 77 says jonathan is there any
symbolic dissonance
when an adult who had been baptized as
an infant is baptized after a conversion
experience
assume both baptisms valid so and far as
being performed in a church with
historic christian beliefs and beliefs
in trying good causality christology
there's there is a doubt there is it's a
it's a messy thing you have to see that
as a really messy situation
and uh
and ultimately in this case what i would
say
is you you
how can i say this it's so like i was
baptized twice and it definitely is an
ideal like i was baptized as a baptist
person
and uh
and then
then i was baptized again when i became
orthodox and so it was at the discretion
of my bishop you know some bishops will
be stricter and
either
demand everybody be baptized or
uh
or demand everybody not be baptized
they've already been baptized because
there is something of
going through baptism another time which
is extremely messy and problematic but
there's also
a reality which is that christianity has
become so diluted and so messy and so
chaotic and so
uh disturbing that it's difficult to
know like it's difficult to be
completely
hard about this uh you know and say that
if you've been if you were baptized you
know no matter where you were whatever
kind of church you were in
uh that that is valid so so i would say
that if you are in a situation where
you're
i would say just you have to
give that responsibility to your
hierarchy you can kind of ask or ask
them if it can be done this way but
ultimately you have to trust that god
works through the church and don't some
people insist
some people will insist to be baptized
when their bishop does not want to be
baptized and then the opposite is true
and this is the wrong way to come into
the church you know because
the the sacraments aren't just a
kind of checklist that you have to get
done right they're also they also
function through our submission to the
hierarchy and our
their capacity to recognize you know the
manner in which the grace of god kind of
comes down so
it's messy all i can say is it's not a
it's not there's no simple answer
um
all right can you explain the symbolism
of this passage from the book of kings
by the word of the lord one of the
company of the prophet said to his
companion strike me with your weapon but
he refused
so the prophet said
because you have not obeyed the lord as
soon as you leave me a lion will kill
you
and after the man went away a lion found
him and killed him
thank you
i don't remember these texts book of
kings man that's tough
i don't think i'm going to answer the
right thing if i answer this
it's definitely super interesting
it's very interesting
huh for some reason like something about
the green knight kind of comes into my
mind but i'm not sure i totally see
how that fits together so well
so so see cs treats all you can you can
say that you stump me so i need to think
about it
all right so jay grubb says
what is the difference between a
nephilim and a god king like julius
caesar or pharaoh the former were
singled out for destruction in a way
that the latter were not would it be
fair to say that the fallen angel
after the flood did not generally reach
the same level of
mixing as the nephilim
except perhaps the nations
of israel
could you say julius was possessed by or
hosting an angel but not
up to the point of producing hybrid
offspring
i think there's definitely a difference
there's definitely a difference um
but what is the difference i mean
i think that the the
i mean i don't know also whether or not
the pharaoh practiced some kind of uh
some kind of sex rijual you know to
create
let's say
to kind of perpetuate this line of
influence from the um
from the from above but i don't think
that's the case to jewish caesar you
know
i think that it's rather something like
they become manifestations of
gods in the world like locusts of gods
in the world and so people kind of
manifest
especially in the case of pharaoh in the
case of julius caesar i think it has
more to do with the idea that his that
his genius or that his spirit you could
say uh
ascended into heaven and took a place in
the uh in the pantheon of the gods
and so i think that that's mostly what
has to do that it has it's it's funny
because
in a way what julius caesar and augustus
caesar was like a strange devious
promise of what christians were actually
going to accomplish
which is the idea that you that you can
uh ascend and participate in the in the
divine council
and so and so it's interesting to see it
that way where
in the past there was an idea that some
people could ascend and become gods and
he was usually very special people you
know like kings like you said or
terrible people like uh certain heroes
that were that were just kind of these
terrible presences in the world
like hercules or other heroes uh whereas
uh
yeah whereas in in christianity you have
a sense that
that we're all called to participate in
the divine council that it's for all who
are willing to to
to be transformed so
all right pkb 5 50 21
says there's a book called sapience by
yuval noah harari that i
have been seeing
that i have seen being read quite a bit
lately it supposedly goes over the
history of humankind but completely
disregards that there is narrative and
even
makes the claim that any ideas we have
of participating in a story is made up
in our head
oh man how can we show people in our
lives that we have that we have meaning
with so many narratives like mentioned
above run rampant what's your opinion on
this i i don't even read the book my
opinion on this is that this guy is
completely unaware of himself in ways
that is just funny and embarrassing
and so there is a book
which is bound in in space and time
which binds words together with chapters
and
and uh and sentences
and coherence with the introduction and
a conclusion i imagine in his book like
all books do you know and uh and in that
book he tells us that all these stories
you know which includes the one he's
telling to you now
are just made up in your head
just
you know you have to almost wish for the
bliss of their ignorance of their of
themselves and how they're part of the
pattern you know
like you wish they they they
so completely unaware of themselves
oh my goodness so anyways i haven't read
the book but the way you describe it
just seems like the same kind of
nonsense you see with that with a lot of
the uh yeah
with a lot of the new atheists and uh
you know and
and uh certain people even in the
so-called idw
all right so here we go
so mark says hi jonathan
i think you missed these three questions
last month well thank you mark uh it is
quite possible that i missed some some
of your questions is it possible let's
see uh
okay so sorry to sound like a heretic
i'm prob i probably am one but you talk
of christ as filling up the hierarchy
does this make him the holy ghost and
not the son of god i think it depends on
your viewpoint
from god's point of view point he is the
son from our
point of view maybe he is the trinity um
i mean
yeah man i that's trinitarian
trinitarian theology
always makes me nervous to talk about
that but
for sure there's a sense in which you
see this in the father's two you have a
sense in which we encounter the trinity
in christ
and that
although there are completely separate
persons we also encounter
the trinity in the three persons that is
because they are bound to each other in
love and kind of feel each other uh
that it that it's not as simple as just
saying three one we're done right it's
far more complicated than that now
um
so
you can understand it
the way in which
the way in which it kind of fills up the
hierarchy
a good way to kind of understand it is
something something like
two movements
one which is the possibility
of
filling and what is what is the actual
concrete
filling and so that's the way that i
kind of see it that is the the holy
ghost is
is is like the it's almost like it see
think of it think of it think of it
exactly like the way you speak
it's that
your word is carried by your breath
and that the breath is the is the
that which kind of opens the space for
meaning to be transmit or carried from
god into
the the the
end of the world
uh
that's the best way that i can explain
it that's the best way that i understand
it and so maybe i'm a heretic people are
gonna come after me
for speculating on the trinity but uh
that's the way i understand it
so i'll say so i'm going on with these
three questions i forgot last month how
do actors nikita 888 ask uh how to act
as the art of acting fit in the symbolic
world view what is the
orthodox perspective on actors
and he gives an example uh i mean i
think actors i mean it's fine to be an
actor
you know
i think that
i kind of bash actors just because
they're so important people give them
way too much importance you know acting
is
is a is ultimately a rather trite uh
thing in the world you know pretending
to be something else
uh but there is like there is an
interesting
symbolism of actors that is that is uh
that can be thought about and it's funny
because i i get this from
it's gino who wrote an article on acting
which i which kind of was interesting
and his idea was that
you can see
in the symbolism of acting
the notion of a center
and then the spokes
and so the the actor
can move out of himself and embody
different aspects of reality without
losing himself so that would be the
proper actor
um
and so something like method acting
would maybe be actually dangerous for
you right because it's like you you try
to just break yourself you try to
destroy your own center
and then just kind of
be possessed you know by the thing that
you're
that you're uh trying to to uh to act
out and you can see that like look at
jim carrey my goodness like he was just
destroyed
it seems like he was just completely
destroyed uh by the man on the moon
movie because he got so completely
possessed by the character that he was
playing that he just never came back
and so i think that that's really
that would be like the dangerous aspect
of acting but you know the the notion of
rather that that a center can move out
and remember itself or not completely
forget itself
but be convincingly let's say embody
different aspects of reality could be a
good
a good symbolism of acting
all right and so he reports a question
from josh the mover is the idea of human
rights a truly christian concept or just
a contrived enlightenment value i'm
mostly tired of hearing about rights but
i'm curious to know if there is an
orthodox framework or at least a sober
symbolic manner of looking at them
we bombastic americans like to say our
rights are from god but it seems more
and more the case that they're just from
government and can easily be erased yeah
good call
so the way that the way that the
christian
worldview seems to formulate this and
it's the way that if you look in
scripture this is what you're going to
find is that
scripture seems to
formulate it as responsibility not as
rights and so
you'll see the prophets go to the kings
and tell the kings
that they need to treat their
flock
with compassion with love as if it's
their children they need to act properly
towards other humans and you see the
same with christ
basically telling us that we need to
love our neighbor that we need to to
treat others like we want to be treated
we need to
to uh to act like the good samaritan you
know and care for
the the downtrodden care for the
suffering go to visit in prisons feed
the the the so it's always framed as
responsibility
whereas
our modern human rights are framed as
rights and so it's the it's actually
people instead of seeing themselves as
responsible
for caring for others they see
themselves as
demanding and
having
uh you know having certain behavior owed
to them
um
and so it's a tricky thing you know
because in a way it's not completely
false right that that because there's
implications that because christ says to
the to the to the strong and to the
powerful that this is how they need to
act unto the weak that it's something
which is
let's say required of them and is due to
the to the weak uh but it's all about
framing when you say it now to the
weaker party then it becomes you know
then it becomes
the rights uh and it leads towards well
at least to what we're seeing now right
it leads to
uh to a kind of pride and a kind of uh
hatred of authority you know uh all of
that so
all right so nicos asked previously you
have spoken about free will
but to be free to be really free to be
bound by god's will it was helpful and i
agree but do we have the ability to
choose be
between to be free in this sense or to
stay imprisoned by our passions and sins
when god calls us out of it if you say
we don't have this ability then you
probably are a calvinist but if we do
have this ability how does providence
work most of the time god's providence
comes
about through human actions if men can
reject god god is dependent on human
choices and providence goes only so far
people accept his calling what do you
make of this and so the way that it's
presented in the in the tradition the
orthodox tradition is is the people talk
of synergy this is obviously not the
word
it's not like a super ancient word but
this is a more later interpretation of
the way that is presented in the
tradition is is synergy and so you can
understand that god is always calling
you god is always calling you to say yes
and and so the opportunity to say yes
is always there and it's not it's not
found in you it's
it really is like it's almost like uh
god is always there to seduce you let's
say and so so even when you sin and i've
talked about this i talked about this
recently right like when you every time
you sin
there's an opportunity which appears
every time
and it's a consequence of the sin but
it's it's it's the sin leading you to
into a place where you can see the
providence of god right you can you can
actually feel it like
a little awake moment
when after you've done something you
shouldn't have or you've given into
something that you shouldn't have you
realize what you've done and then
there's this opening now this opening is
something that you can
either ignore
or you can just grab onto
attend to is al almost enough
attend to that opening and then in that
attention
you'll find space there's space in that
attention and and then this is when the
synergistic thing happens which is that
doesn't mean you're not going to
fall again or fall into your passions
again but it's
you know but then that attention can
grow
and that and then instead of
and then you can hone your attention
through prayer through through
not spending your time on the things
that will bring you into your sinful
world in the first place to to to to
meditating on holy things to
to look upon holy things to you know to
sing to do all these things which are
gathering your attention in the right
places
so that when you
when you
have that opportunity you you just grab
it that's all i can say
uh but that doesn't the first call
doesn't come from you right the grace
doesn't come from you and it's the same
with the sacraments and so you can
imagine that the sacraments are like
this call you know this moment that are
that is calling you into the life of god
and you can and it's always there right
it's like your baptism is there in your
life and your experience in your even if
you don't remember it because you you're
baptized as a child it's still there
right in your
identity you could say and so it's
there's a there's a capacity to
to just hold on to it and then
then there's more providence and more
grace and then you kind of there's this
back and forth uh movement and so i'm
definitely not a calvinist
but
it's always grace first that's for sure
um
i hope that makes sense man it's like
these kind of questions are hard because
it seems like i i'm saying things that a
lot of people might not even understand
what i'm talking about hopefully you've
had that experience and i'm talking just
from my own experience
um
all right timothy timothy aspeslaw says
hey jonathan you recently mentioned how
movies always picture the middle ages as
drab brown and bleak do you have any
recommendations for for media that
get their representation of middle ages
right alternatively can you recommend
more books on art that focus on the
middle ages
can be either text or photo based um
i mean you can have plenty of books that
focus on the middle ages i mean you just
go just look online and look at middle
ages
you know middle age tapestries middle
age interiors middle age frescoes you
can just look that up online now in
terms of media there's a there are a few
there's not a lot there's an interesting
series uh russian series called sophia
and uh
it's pretty amazing like in it's the
story is it's also i don't know i i i i
wasn't super
seduced by the story let's say it's kind
of interesting but
the the the visuals are just astounding
you know
there they have these
highly ornate clothing with gold and you
know and then all the walls are painted
in frescoes especially in the in the um
especially in the uh the castle like the
kings the king's palace um and you know
all this this jewelry and everything of
course it's a royal family so it's it's
more ornate than you would have seen
let's say in the middle ages but it gets
given give you a sense of like the
the love that the medievals had for
color and ornament and uh so uh so yeah
but in terms of other stuff i haven't
seen a lot it's just i don't know why
it's the same with like how they
represent the roman and greek world they
also often represent that as white you
know with white marble statues and all
this stuff but none of it was like that
you know it was all color
people love ancient people love color
just like
less modern people love color even now
today like go
go to a village in mexico and you'll see
like a catholic church will be just
covered in color the statue is all
painted and you know ornaments you know
these these patterns all over the wall
and you know this kind of luscious uh
world so
yeah all right hopefully that's helpful
all right so
unless i am mistaken i am done on um
on this on the the website so
also one of the reasons why sometimes i
might miss the questions is that if you
put them in
you know while i'm doing the q a then
i'm not gonna get them because i'm not
gonna refresh uh and so just to warn you
next month i will stop the q a
questions
uh like a day before so to have time to
be able to manage to manage the
questions uh so
so uh that means on my part i have to
promise that i won't post the questions
like the the
won't post the possibility of questions
three days before which is what i've
been which i did this month so sorry to
everybody i'll try to post it at least
like a week and a half or two week in
advance but the there'll be a cut off
also
all right
okay so let's see
all right so here on patreon now uh
justin seligman says hi jonathan can you
please talk about the symbolism of
deacons
in both the liturgy iconography and the
broader life of the church thank you and
so
i mean sure
the the deacons it's interesting to see
like the deacons uh
they're they kind of show you the
hierarchy like the because the deacons
are almost like a transition well
there's more transitions right because
you have canter and then you have all
these lower orders but you can
understand all the orders as just this
kind of
hierarchy that moves into the faithful
and it's almost
it can be indefinitely you know kind of
cut up and then you have ultra servers
which aren't at all part of the clergy
but nonetheless kind of participate in
the clergy and everything um
and so deacons are something like
you know they're they're kind of like
this in between space between the
between the altar and the people and so
they have there's something about them
which is kind of bombastic and loud and
uh
and running around you know they run
around all the time and uh
that's i think that's the best way to
understand deacons you know they
they're in closer service to the
to the people and they're also kind of
in closer service to
the the clergy they're kind of like this
in between
in between thing
um
all right so drew mcmahon man asked hi
jonathan what are your thoughts on magic
maybe i'm making it up but it seems to
be showing up in culture more recently
and so man that word magic that's a
really vague word i don't know what you
mean by that you mean like the magic the
way that uh cs lewis talked about the
deep magic
that was really just basically the kind
of uh the patterns and this
this this music which is playing in
behind the world you mean magic in the
grosser kind of vulgar sense of
using your will through ritual to affect
reality
um
and so i think that if it's the second
one it's going to be inevitable that it
that it takes up more space in our
culture because people will realize that
you can affect the world through will
and it doesn't necessarily involve
complicated rituals right you can see
how
through ritual like
let me let me kind of break it down
really really at a basic just the most
boring level that you can find it's like
you can use media
and ritualize speech
to change the structure of reality
so you can tell something you can say
something in a certain way
which will
affect the way people perceive it
and will then actually transform the
thing into that which you said
so that's magic now there are more
there are more
um
subtle ways there are some more subtle
types of magic there are more ritualized
versions of magic but i would say that
for christians at least this is just not
this is not the type of thing that you
need to be too attentive to
because
it's a kind of instrumentalization
of logos and an instrumentalization of
the capacities god has given us to be
intermediaries between heaven and earth
and and to be locusts of meaning and
those that gather phenomena into them
and so it's using that truth to now
affect the world for my own advantage
and so
in that sense of magic i think it is
definitely a problem but i'm also not
surprised
that it's going to appear more and more
you know on our horizon
so micah mueller says hi jonathan
thought this might be a good match enoch
elias is an ethiopian deacon would love
to do a talk
and so micah that talk is already
recorded
and so i talked to uh uh deacon enoch uh
was it two weeks ago but now you know
since i've been back from covert i've
just been lining up i've just been
recording like mad i have a lot of
interviews that are in the uh that are
in the hopper and so we're gonna we're
gonna try to put them out a little more
frequently so that i can kind of run
through them but i had an amazing
discussion with deacon enoch it was
super interesting and he
you know ethiopian tradition is so
fascinating so i'll i'll let you watch
it to discover some of the really
interesting stuff that he that he that
he talked about so
all right so nathan condon asked well
hello jonathan my question has to do
with cremation
a family member of mine has always
wanted me to cremate them and spread
their ashes when they pass i want to
respect their wishes but worry about
doing so as a christian what is your
advice
you know
i mean all i can say is that it that the
christian tradition is to bury
uh
derek fielder says the hopper do you
know not that expression it means
they're it's like they're they're
they're
they're like there they're kind of
bouncing around and then you have to
take them out like if they're in line
they're they're excited to be next but
they're not next yet so um all right so
all i can tell you is that it's not the
the the tradition the traditional
christian uh tradition is is to be
buried just because
there are all kinds of implications
about being buried and there are all
kinds of implications towards cremation
now
like i said i've said this before in
another q a it doesn't mean that if
you're cremated you're going to go to
hell or any stupid thing like that it
has nothing to do with that
but i think that we need to
understand that
gestures have
side effects that are not directly
visible in the thing we do and that's
why many meaningful acts and even things
people might consider superstition
are
not superstitious they're not
necessarily uh stupid because people
don't aren't able to see
the
the side effects or the embodiment of
that pattern in the world and how in
order for
certain patterns to be real there needs
to be all these other things that are
that are uh
collated to that and so that's why and
and i'm not gonna explain it here i've
explained it in another q a before but
that's why
uh burial is is important but you know i
would say
i mean i would say it's probably best to
follow the person's uh wishes if they're
not orthodox if they're not you know
it's like i don't know what to tell you
you know it's
it's it's it's it's
you know and if they don't want to kind
of participate in the christian
tradition you can't force them and so i
would say just cremate them you know
there's other there are things like that
in the tradition too you know when when
they
if a non-baptized person died in in the
ancient uh world they would not bury
them in a cemetery they would bury them
in a mass grave you know
and uh you know because they just
weren't they weren't allowed to kind of
participate in this liturgical
reality and so if people self-exclude
themselves from that then you shouldn't
i don't think you should oppose them
all right so uh dushan
babich
thank you for telling me how to
pronounce that i hope i got it right
what is the symbolism of judge 19 29 man
you guys bring me into symbol into
judges and kings what are you doing and
when he was coming to the house he took
a knife
and they'd hold on his concubine and
divided her together with her bones into
twelve pieces and sent her into all the
coasts of israel
uh and so you know what man
i'm really happy that you i'm really
happy that you um
stumbled onto one of the most difficult
and and and difficult verses in
scripture you know and uh and i
how can i say this matter has a very
good understanding of this i have a
pretty good understanding of this
but i i'm not ready to explain it yet
um
and so sorry man
but uh you know i i'll get there i
promise you i will get to explaining
that story in scripture because it is a
crazy story
um
because there's a there's a lot of other
stuff going on in that story which is
just nuts right it's not just about
him having his concubine cut up is that
it's like uh if you know the story he
goes to to to this to the
to a house and he's with his
his his with his mistress basically with
the concubine
and then like sodom and gomorrah people
come to the house and want to abuse the
man
and so he basically puts out his
concubine outside to be
abused and she gets and then he goes to
bed and he falls asleep and then they
kill her
and then when he wakes up in the morning
he goes crazy because they killed her
and now he cuts her up into 12 and i
mean it's nuts
and so
it's completely nuts you know and it has
to do with uh
it has to do with the tribe of dan as
well and all that kind of left-handed
stuff so so we'll we'll one day we'll
get into that
what i would i really need to do is
convince mature to write about that
because he's he would be really good at
that
um
all right okay so here we go
so brett says why do moses jesus and
paul venture through the desert hell on
earth death dry etc instead of
a place like the garden of eden heaven
on earth life water to find god i think
it has to do with god is always with us
even when we are going through hell
tough times the lord reveals themselves
to us when we are the most vulnerable
and we realize uh of our garments skin
can no longer protect us from what's
about to happen let me know what you
think uh and so
there's a lot of stuff
let me just do something here
all right and so the the best way to to
understand that it has to do with
transition
it has to do with moving
from
one world to another or moving into
a new world or think about it this way
think of it in terms of christ right uh
being tempted
being
going through a kind of
a temptation or a tribulation you could
say
um
and so it's it's think of it like uh
think of it
like a purification like baptism right
it's
it's like this burning off of
the the let's say in terms of moses and
egyptians think of that they left egypt
as the mixed multitude
and and there was good stuff and bad
stuff and all this kind of chaos in
there and so they go through the desert
to burn off
all the stuff that doesn't belong
in the holy land and in the story
in the story of israel it is insane it's
a crazy story
because the only two people
from the entire original group
when they get through the desert enter
into the promised land it's almost like
the story of noah
the passing of
of israel from egypt to the promised
land is similar to the flood
because everybody dies
in the desert
it's crazy but i mean it's if you want
to understand it symbolically you have
to understand it as a form of
purification it's like a form of
of uh of burning off all the things that
are holding you back and that belong to
the ancient you
uh and keeping only the seed keeping
only the divine logos
so that you can find the new body right
and so that's what baptism is as well um
and so that's and so what you so what
you see
in
in um
in the story of christ when he goes out
to the desert then
he experiences it as temptation
and so it's like it presents itself as
this temptation to move out of himself
and to give in to the to the chaos and
give in to the the fragmentation and the
multiplicity
uh
and he does it right and he he remains
in the heart you could say
um
so there are different ways to see it
right you can see it as a burning off or
as temptation which in the case of
crisis then resisted you know
so yeah all right
all right so jimmy spa hijab says what
what's the theological difference
between catholicism and orthodoxy
i'm catholic married to greek orthodox
and personally i only think it's a
cultural difference but the face is the
same but maybe there's more to it than
what i've noticed and so uh i would say
it's not completely the same because
it's just i mean it's not and and it's
interesting because you really do see
that catholic people tend to think that
the orthodox are like them and then the
orthodox tend to think that the
catholics are not like them and so if
you want to understand one of the
dynamics between the two that is
definitely
one of them there's a meme going around
uh you know where it's like i forget who
it is like these two people and someone
asked them are you two friends and then
one says yes and the other one says no
it's like that's the kind of that's the
that's the kind of catholic orthodox
joke um
and so i mean what are the theological
differences there are plenty you know
you can look them up online you can find
many people who are wanting to discuss
that and wanting to explore that but
ultimately i think that
uh
at least in my vision at least in the
situation we are in now i it seems like
in the orthodox tradition
there's more of
the seed or the or the the spark or the
the the kind of mystical tradition this
kind of cosmic vision that i present
that has been preserved
but it's still there in the catholic
church kind of implicitly but it's just
not as
seems like it's not as
embodied let's say
all right so our murray says please
comment on the symbolism of the the
caduceus and if you can compare to the
symbolism of the current american
medical association logo
does this say anything about the
healthcare historically and currently um
and so
so there's a difference between the
caduceus and the medical association
logo
because the medical is the the medical
logo that you see is is based on uh
why is it that my brain isn't working
it's based on the sleepiest it's based
on the rod of asclepius and not the
caduceus and the rod of asclepius
usually has one serpent on it now in the
legend of asclepius it seems to be
suggested that there are two aspects to
the serpent and so for example there's a
legend which says that um
asclepius was the it was a was met he
healed people with serpents
and he would take blood from the right
side of the serpent
in order to heal people not from the
left side because
suggesting that the blood from the left
side of the serpent or the gorgon in
this case right the serpent woman the
serpent monster that the blood from the
left side of the serpent monster
was poison right so you have this idea
of poison and cure
um
and so
you can see that it's related to the
caduceus
if you understand the caduceus of course
as the
as the the the
the staff of hermes and the whole
relationship between the idea of the
messenger of the gods the messenger of
the gods you could say is the one that
moves between
that which is above and below he's kind
of the the extension of the gods into
the world and so has two sides to him
you know can be a positive message or a
negative message and so it also is
related to
to the traditions of of of uh
of hermes in general and even the more
kind of hermetic traditions of of hermes
which is that
the way in which you act on the world
has this duality no matter what it is
right medical is just one version of it
i talked about this in terms of the
duality of the garments of skin is a way
to understand it and so the caduceus is
just one version of that so you can
understand it as two serpents two sides
good and bad and so and so it it uh
right the the orthodox bishop has a
staff which has two serpents on it and
it you could say that it's the same
symbolism as the caduceus but it's not a
negative it's not a bad symbolism you're
right it's christ with the good thief
and the bad thief and so the extensions
the one moving closer to christ or
moving away from christ and so
understand the the in between as that
moving towards the gods or away from the
gods or manifesting the will of the gods
or the displeasure of the gods it's like
this duality which appears in
the in extensions so i feel like when i
talk about this kind of stuff it's like
it's so it's i'm being very hermetic
sorry or very just obscure and and
people won't understand what i'm talking
about so sorry i hope some people
understand what i'm talking about
um all right sorry
so garrett whitner hi jonathan what is
the symbolism of a maiden in a tower who
escapes using hair this is rapunzel of
course but i also
uh what i also just came across it in
token similarion where luthien is in
prison in a tall tree and chance her
hair to grow
weaves it into a cloak to mask her
beauty so she doesn't recognize and then
weaves the rest
into a rope to escape
i don't understand it at all
what is the connection between hair and
escape from a high place what is the
meaning of a place that is also a prison
being high and so
all right so
i think i've explained this before
i have a i have us i have a video called
the symbolism of hair uh and i think
that you could probably watch that and
understand but i can explain it
it has to do with extensions it has to
do with the extensions that we just
talked about so think of hair as an
extension of you
right that is both your glory
but also
your uh
dead
covering okay so it's both at the same
time and so
the woman up in the
the the tower is the
feminine aspect
of that which is in of the ideal right
the feminine aspect of the ideal just
like
just like close to the notion of the
mother of god you could say are close to
the notion of beatrice in dante you know
this that
and it's that which
it's the veil and the unveiling right
it's the it's the veil on the holy place
it's the veiling unveiling of the of the
secret place where the seed is hidden
where the the union of heaven and earth
happens and so
think in the story of rapunzel you see
and in the virgin you told me it's
exactly the same and so in the story of
rapunzel
the hair
which is like the glory of the this or
the manifestation of this down into the
world
is a way to climb up in order to reach
in this mystery and so all the forms in
the world right the rituals the the the
icons the the all of these are like a
ladder
they're not the things in themselves are
not
are not the absolute good but they're
like little steps and so as you
encounter the scriptures you know you
you read these verses you encounter the
icons you you you have all these forms
these songs this this all these things
that extend out of the secret place
where the logos is hidden
um and so it's a ladder so you climb it
right
you you if you
how can i say this it's like if there's
recognition
between
you and that if there's memory and
recognition then the the steps
are steps then all these forms all of
these things that manifest become steps
but if you are seduced by
the hair itself
if the hair becomes an
obstacle the hair can become an obstacle
of you seeing what is behind if you're
if you're not properly oriented so in
the version of rapunzel
what ha what makes the prince blind what
makes him now incapable of knowledge
is that
he fails to recognize that the hair has
been cut off
that the hair has been has been cut off
and that it is now a false ladder
towards a wicked principle
so it's idols basically so it's become
idols all these steps because he's
incapable of recognizing the highest
thing have all become idols and so as he
climbs them he falls
and he is
and he is uh and he is blinded so
it's just the story of adam and eve in
the garden guys it's the same story
it's understanding that think of it this
way that
god was going to give adam and eve the
fruit of the knowledge of good and evil
but in order for them to get it they had
to recognize that it came from god that
to recognize and stay in their
connection
to that which out of which this fruit
was coming
but as soon as they see the fruit as
good in itself as appeasing to the
senses in themselves and they re they
cease to remember the origin of it
then when they eat it
when they grab onto that hair and start
climbing they fall into the thorns just
like the prince falls into the thorns
and they become blind
it's just the story of adam and eve guys
and so it has to do with the garments of
skin all of this has to do with the
garments of skin so the garments of skin
they are layers
of the glory of god
right just like the garments of skin on
the temple so the hair
hairy garments and the different
separators on the temple are actually
steps in a ladder
moving into the holy of holies
but they're also separators they also
make you further from the glory of god
and if you're not careful and you
idolize the garments if you idolize
technology
anything that is an exterior form
then you increase the fall and what you
end up doing is you end up wanting to
add more
more layers and so in the story
of rapunzel how is he healed he's healed
the prince he's healed because he
recognizes her voice again
he hears her voice
and in his blindness
he recognizes her
and so as he recognizes her
the water from paradise the rivers of
paradise
come down onto the prince
and heal him from his blindness
yeah that's what it is it's just the
story of adam and eve
hopefully this makes sense
all right
um
so janet horseman says at least some
ladies i know have started wearing a
shirt with an image of a skull on its
side a ten peg through the skull's
temple and biblical womanhood and judges
four five written underneath one could
easily find an image of the shirt online
a year ago i probably would have gotten
the shirt as well but having found the
symbolic world the idea of a strange
figure like jail
representing biblical womanhood seems
backwards what is this odd story about
is wearing such a shirt
harmless um
i don't know i mean it depends in what
spirit it's being worn it's if it's worn
in a kind of weird you know
feminism thing it's probably not great
but it's
it's it seems a little funny uh which
you know it's okay but i mean i think
the idea also that that uh
let's say womanhood you have images
there are images of uh saints of the
mother of god i think even
of her
like doing the same like i i forget or
maybe it's not the mother god but i i i
remember very specifically a female
saint that's like nailing you know like
like bashing demons on the head and like
nailing them
down
and so
let me give you a little mystery about
jail is that you're right there's
something off about that story
but
there's also something which is pointing
us
there's also something in that story
which is actually pointing us towards
mary
uh and the mother of god because
in the store of jail you know she she
it's a very interesting it's a very
interesting thing which is that
jail
uses
the tropes of seduction and woman and
motherhood and so the king comes into
her tent
and she covers him and she gives him
milk i think and she she makes him
comfortable right and she puts them to
sleep you know and there's some sexual
undertones to it it's not explicitly in
the tech but there's some sexual
undertone but it's it's it's vague
because it's like it's a kind of caring
that she has for this king and then
and then in that moment she
she uses that to kill
the foreign king basically um
you have to remember that that's what he
is right he's the strange king he's the
strange husband he's not her husband
he's not her king he's this he's he's
this he's the and so
and so it's it's a it's a powerful image
of
the feminine as well and the feminine's
capacity to recognize
her own
husband right her own king her own
but also her own uh child but
it also strangely points to the story of
the story of christ because
you could say that the mother of god
the mother of god fixes jail
because
she
is the mother
of the one who is going to die
and so
if you look at an image of the um of the
nativity
so you will see
christ in the manger with the mother of
god you know laying down
be you know next to him or below him
kind of as this kind of body still that
that contains him
um
and uh but in the cave right the
the um the manger is also a tomb and it
looks like a tomb and we always have to
remember that if you look in christ halo
there's always a cross
in christ's hail christ's halo
in
his head or around his head going
towards his head
and so
the icon of the nativity is actually the
ultimate like
fullness of the story of jail you know
where it's turned towards salvation you
could say
this aspect of uh
of womanhood
and it's very mysterious but it it seems
pretty clear that it's there in the
story
um all right so chase and lindsay said
hey jonathan
uh i've noticed in a lot of media in the
past 30 years that there seems to be a
recurring pattern of portraying the
archangel gabriel as an antagonist and
villain yeah
just a small sample of films where this
happens is the prophecy constantine
legion and dominion is there any reason
why poor gabriel would be portrayed in
such a negative light and this seems to
have become
a pattern
i can't seem to find any indication of
gabriel having hostile intent or
becoming a fallen angel in scripture
or even in other
old extra biblical texts
so
it's very crass it's crass and it's
anti-religious and it's stupid and and
you know there's all that but there's
something
there's a mystery in there's a mystery
in um
gabriel uh
you know gabriel is the it's the word
gabriel the name has to do with with uh
with
people translate it as power but it also
can have something to do with a kind of
uh
harshness like the harshness of god and
so in in rabbinical
interpretation gabriel is the left hand
uh
of god
and is actually associated with
kind of the sword and with fire and of
all this kind of imagery
um
and what's interesting is that in
christianity it's flipped
it's flipped where gabriel you often is
in blue and has a lily and michael is in
red and has a sword but it's kind of
inverted it's flipped from from
rabbinical interpretation so i think
that in movies where they tend to show
gabriel
as being a kind of darker figure or a
harsher figure i think they're taking
from
they're taking from jewish uh jewish
sources
uh and but still like making them trite
and pathetic because i don't think any
rabbi that respects himself would say
that because gabriel is the
is the the gebura right that he's the
he's the harshness or the
you know that aspect of of god that he's
evil or all that kind of stuff anyways
so yeah
so josh says hello jonathan hope that
you are well my question got away from
me as i pondered over today so i'll try
and simplify it for the sake of brevity
if sainthood is rooted in being
conformed to the image of christ it
seems reasonable that the inversion of
this would be transfiguration by our own
hands
have you seen examples of this in
current media thanks so much for your
time and thoughts well yeah of course i
mean that's what the entire
transhumanist uh
move is transfiguration by our own hands
right you know
all this all this insanity of having
chips inserted in your brain and you
know of making ourselves more than human
of uploading your consciousness to
computer all of this is a parody
of uh of the transfiguration you know
so
yeah
so dan diego de la vega says uh hello
jonathan reading the psalms made me
reflect on the historical events of the
roman civil war and the fate of pompeii
what do you say the symbolic
significance of the roman general pompey
who desecrated the temple in jerusalem
at the top of his success and fame
then years later after losing the roman
civil war was murdered in egypt by
assassins then decapitated with his head
placed into a basket to present to
caesar um
i mean
you know it's like i i agree that
definitely there seems to be an
interesting
symbolism happens moment here
but uh but yeah but i never i never
necessarily thought of it that way
i mean it is interesting that he's
murdered in egypt right interesting you
know and then decapitated so
interesting yeah there's i think there
definitely is a connection
there for sure it's like something that
you could find in in scripture right
like the story of jezebel or something
like that it seems like that that part
of the story uh
it could be found in scripture
all right uh walrus queen 14 says god
bless you jonathan perhaps you can help
me to interpret a recent dream
a close friend of mine had um all right
let's see what this is i'm not a big fan
of the dream interpretation things you
guys probably know that
right the drinker place in a local
neighborhood a group of teenagers found
a hidden cave that they started
exploring at the end of which they found
a dragon which they attacked and killed
people were referring to the dragon as
the first dragon after its teeth the
teenagers after its death the teenagers
left the cave to find a second dragon
was attacking the neighborhood this one
being called the last dragon however it
was only attacking cars
those who are not driving around were
safe from its attacks
i don't know i have some ideas of my
knowing what dragons and caves normally
symbolize but i want to hear if you have
any ideas also don't worry
i don't plan to tell them any of this or
get overly fixated on it or something
i'm just trying to test my symbolic
skills um
i mean a simple way to understand it
could be something like
that the first dragon is hidden in a
cave is something like the seed of
transformation
you know uh
and the last dragon is attacking things
that move is is kind of like the final
fruit of transformation or change you
could say
and so
you know if you kill the first dragon in
the cave if you kill the meaning or the
seed or the the origin of a change
then
that change is is because it loses its
meaning just becomes arbitrary and out
of control and out of control especially
uh and will
and will lead to fragmentation uh which
is represented by
this burning of the cars you know
so
i mean that's as close as i'm going to
get to any of that
so norman grenade said throughout the
gospels why are the demons better able
to identify and know who christ is
whereas his own disciples and followers
seem to struggle with recognizing his
true nature even failing to hear or
understand his warning
of his coming death despite repeated
attempts i mean it's because demons are
not embodied they're not embodied they
see patterns they they see
they
right they see your soul right they they
the in fleshing of the divine logos is
was also like a veil it was hiding him
uh and so that's why people couldn't
really see him or would great difficulty
see him
and so that's why right and so the the
the demons were not
were not uh
yeah because they could see behind there
they themselves are disembodied and so
they can they can see patterns
all right marcus david you recently said
in a tweet that the mandated
injections are quote pretty much
the mark
but pretty much did you mean that it's a
precursor or that it's actually is it i
mean i think i answered this already
it's it's definitely
it's it's moving towards moving in that
direction is the best way to understand
it you know
um
yeah
uh so dorothea says is cannibalism a
form of seeking intimacy from others
apart from it being a search for meaning
i've been watching attack on titan and
it came to my mind especially since the
titan
can't reproduce by themselves
um
and so
cannibalism is is is uh
the foremost is circular causation right
that's what cannibalism is uh
how you pronounce it anthro i don't know
how to pronounce it i mean man eating so
man eating isn't exactly the same as
cannibalism right and so man eating like
man-eating monsters
are
the idea of potential or the or the
things on the outside
being able to kind of devour your seed
or make you waste your seed or you know
take the meaning away from you or spread
the meaning out into the wild let's say
uh you know
rip you to rip you apart in the
wilderness right it's a good image of it
you know uh and you see that in attack
on titan now they tend to like rip the
people apart a lot um so there's that
but cannibalism is a little is different
it's man-eating but it it's it really is
a
a form of a desire for
for kind of this this circular causation
you know
um
it has to do cannibalism has to do with
incest and all these kind of problems of
of not getting potential from the
outside but rather recirculating
potential on the inside of a system
um so that at some point it becomes uh
becomes kind of twisted and it falls it
makes the system fall apart
so
yeah
so that's what cannibalism is all right
so manuel montiel says it seems like the
new age movement is morphing into a form
of christian gnosticism
with ideas like inner or secret
spiritual knowledge of god which jesus
considered an example of it but not
actually god incarnate and the use of
apocryphal and other religious acts to
validate these ideas do you think this
is true and does the idea of assyria
play a role in it after all we modern
men love things that come easy um
i mean i don't know only if the new age
movement is morphing into a form of
christian narcissism new age is just new
age it's just a bunch of stuff it's
it's as idiosyncratic as every new age
practitioner ultimately you know it's
idiosyncrasy itself it's kind of mixing
and matching and doing all that kind of
stuff so that's mostly what it has to do
with the kind of breaking a part of the
christian narrative and then this
breakdown into all these foreign and
strange and idiosyncratic practices and
you know anything from yogis and tantra
to crystals and all this kind of this
kind of stuff that gets mixed up
together and is just a hodgepodge you
know uh and so there's a relationship
between these gnostic these new gnostics
uh in the sense of the idea of using
apocryphal especially the the nagamadi
codex especially those that use these
texts that are found buried in the
ground you know and
using it to destroy christianity you
know this is so it
it's related to the new age movement in
the sense that
like an image of the breakdown is this
kind of chaotic movement idiosyncrasy
and the strange and all this but another
image of the breakdown is the the return
of the rejected we talked about this in
other guises that is the things that are
rejected at the end of a system they
come back and start to devour or judge
the system so
the marginal things
right the things that are cast out the
castaways think of it as the goat of
azazel like moving out
and then coming back
into the camp let's say
in order to judge those that cast it out
because there's this problem of
completeness and
and uh and coherence
and so this is what happens at the end
of anything so there are ways to deal
with that but
we're noticing we're seeing it happen
and so
the the use of apocryphal texts to
destroy christianity is is really the
same
drive which is
creating
intersectional
culture
because it has to do with
using that which was rejected to judge
the order of a system
hopefully that brings a little further
down that road so
so aquadox asks
from the christian conception of the
world is there a point to secular art
besides obfuscation
and protection when coming down the
mountain
what you talked about in the cane story
should christians christian make novels
in movies like conan sherlock holmes or
faust why
it's all about hierarchy guys it's all
about you know i just told you i'm
making a graphic novel you know
it's all about
things being in their proper place you
know so think about it exactly like this
problem of the mountain coming down the
mountain which is that
the further down you are on the mountain
think of the waters being diluted right
as they come down the mountain saint
ephraim has this idea where the waters
of life at the top of the mountain as
they come down the mountain they're
somewhat deluded and they lose their
saver and they get mixed and with the
savers of the world right so think about
it that way and but they're still
further like they're further bringing
water water further out and so think of
the arts like that think of the art as a
hierarchy of
of of layers but those layers are both
good and bad just like the problem of
the of the hair that we talked about you
know a few minutes ago that is that the
secular arts the novels the movies all
of this
can be a way
in which to bring things further out
into the world to to reach more quantity
but ultimately in order to do that you
often end up having to sacrifice quality
if you understand it consciously and you
understand that it's at the level where
it has to be
then it can be fine
the problem
is always when people put things in the
wrong place
the problem is when people
think that that that watching a movie in
church is the equivalent of the liturgy
or people who think that
you know some novel
has the same amount of power and insight
and participation
as the scriptures or as our holy
traditions and so
this is the problem and so you could say
that the problem of modern culture
is not that there are secular forms of
art and more participative or even
entertaining forms of art it's that
we've made those the center of our
culture we've made those the most
important things
we've made those the ones that we
celebrate
right and so we celebrate
these
these kind of lowly forms
as if they are the very source of
culture itself and as if they are the
very
reason for culture
hope that makes sense
so a wavering radiant asca you know i've
only discovered recently after a quick
scan of patreon it seems the one that
asked yes i was wondering if you've seen
the movie the green knight and if so
what are your thoughts
uh personally i found it incredibly rich
in symbolism and depth so much so that i
had to watch it a second time and wanted
to watch the third and i feel like i
still haven't grasped all that it has to
say
i'm gonna disappoint you man i'm gonna
totally disappoint you a wavering
radiant i don't know what to tell you i
did see it and
okay
there are some interesting things in the
movie
but you have to see it in its proper you
have to see it in its frame
you have to see it in its frame which
matches the frame of all the cultural
things and so i'm going to spoil this
movie for you guys if you haven't
watched it you know block your ears stop
listening or whatever i'm going to
totally spoil it right now because i
have to spoil it to explain this problem
the movie starts with
with going sitting on a throne
he's holding a scepter and a globe in
his hand and so manifesting the medieval
king the holy emperor
this is what he's manifesting
and a crown comes down from heaven
to fall on his head so right now it's
all good this is it right the crown
coming from above right being crowned
from heaven coming down from above in
order to manifest his kingship
then when the crown lands on his head he
bursts on fire
it's already that's the entire movie
that's the whole movie that it's all
that's what it's all about okay
so
i'm not going to go into the details of
the story but i'm going to tell you how
it ends
so
at the end of the movie there's an
ambiguity about whether or not gohan
gets his head cut off or not okay
but what there's no ambiguity about is
that after the credits there's a
post-credit scene which cinches the
whole symbolism of the movie
which is that there's the crown of going
on the ground remember the crown that
came down from heaven to land on
gawain's head as he was sitting there on
the throne in the guise of an emperor
the crown is on the floor
and a little girl walks in
she takes the crown
and she puts it on her head
and if you want to understand the
symbolism of that movie
that's what it is
and and i'm not saying there aren't some
interesting aspects to it there isn't
some good symbolism in it there is
but ultimately
that's the frame of the movie and it
just strangely happens to fit with the
frame of every other story which is
being told by hollywood
right now
whether it's he-man or marvel or
everything and it's completely in tune
with what i've talked about in terms of
terms of the idea of self-sacrifice
as a trick to replace the masculine hero
the male figure with a female figure you
know and so even the tropes that are
positive because there is a sense of
self-sacrifice
in gawain you know where
he accepts the consequence of his
actions he accepts to take the blow of
the night instead of
lying in a kind of passion of christ's
little last temptation or whatever and
going back into the world and then you
know finally really losing his head
because he gives in to all these all
this politics and all this kind of
playing uh and so you're like yeah
that's it you know that's that that's
that's it but then
then it just becomes he-man right it
becomes the same story as he-man and the
same story is logan and all these
stories of of
the masculine hero sacrificing himself
in order to be replaced
and it's just it's just too bad i hate
to have to see it that way but that's
what's there in the story and it just
fits with everything else so sorry man
watch it again watch it now with that in
mind and then watch all the other
stories
right watch all the other aspects and
you'll see that the entire movie is
about gawain deal dealing
failing and succeeding but strangely
succeeding with the feminine
right
giving the head back to the feminine
that's the story dude that's why he
that's why
that's why that saint is that's why he
meets that saint that's not in the
original story
he goes down into the water to find this
the head of the dead woman and puts the
head back on her
in order to save her and it's like that
story is totally fine it's great it's a
great story but if you stitch it all
together
it's just the same thing the same
nonsense
all right so david luters i'm going way
too long of these questions guys sorry
so david luther says hi jonathan firstly
if you say my last name it's pronounced
litters sorry david litters all right um
i enjoyed your appearance on the babylon
b i think it will be my new go-to video
for introducing symbolic thought to
people interested
thank you i enjoyed that discussion as
well
um
so anyways my question has to do with
the symbolism of ice and temperature
more generally two instances of
disappearing significantly in stories
come from the mind come to the mind the
ninth circle of hell in dante's inferno
the second is the story of fourier a
mathematician who made major
contributions to
equations relating to dispersion and
heat related equations he he was known
to always feel cold even during
i guess during summer i guess it's not
there but if his feel cold especially
during
summer despite wearing multiple thick
coats at all times thanks in advance for
your patience with all these long
questions so i don't know anything about
um
this fourier guy uh but um
but i mean i think that in in the in the
sense of uh of dante it's it's a really
interesting like game that dante plays
because
there's a sense in which
there's there's essentially what the
image of ice is especially dante it's
it's like
fire is still the possibility of
change right it's still
there's still something about fire and
it's actually
it's subtly there in dante you know and
and and i can show you where it is i was
reading the inferno again recently and
there some subtle hints in dante you
know that what he's seeing there is not
permanent right that there's
that there's possibility for for a
change uh but ice like when you get to
the ice it's as if
it's the thing which
doesn't even have the possibility for
change it's the thing that doesn't even
have so
think of it like
what dante is seeing in hell are is
people that are burning
because their love is in the wrong place
and so they're burning
from love
love is making them burn but they're but
because they love the wrong things or
they love things
in the wrong order
that is why they are burning okay
um
but then if you betray right because
that's the last circle of hell
betrayal is acting against love itself
so that's why dante sees it as the
ultimate sin and i think that that's why
dante puts ice down there in the lower
circle of hell because
it's actually the absence of love you
know
um
i think that's what he's trying to show
so
so white lawrence says what is the
symbolism of synthetic mind-altering
drugs
xanax adderall zoloft ritalin etc you
know
i don't man it's all
it's all it's all it's all i can i mean
it's it's it's all watchmen and nephilim
you know it's it's all moving in that
direction it's all not it's all
i mean i'm not saying there's something
wrong with taking uh let's say a
a medicine which will help you but uh
but let's say the culture of of sedation
and of
of transforming your mind through
supplement
transforming intelligence through
supplement you know you could say that
the thrust to create mind-altering drugs
is the same thrust which is bringing us
to desire artificial intelligence you
know and that kind of stuff so
so randall b said jesus walked for 40
days in the desert and he walked
the earth for 40 days after the
resurrection before his ascension
are these two walks of joining of
opposites in some way
i don't know i mean it has to do with a
cycle it's probably the best way to
understand it is like a cycle 40 40 days
is like a
sorry
just like the 40 years um
in the in the desert so i don't totally
understand the numerical aspect of that
but it it seems to just be like a like a
section like a cycle you know
all right so charlie and gloria says
hello jonathan i've been inspired to
start making short films again after
hearing you say that there's a need for
better stories
uh the type of film i made back in the
day and one that i am a fan of is horror
being that i'm going to be christmated
into the orthodox church soon is this
type of movie something i shouldn't be
perusing anymore
is there a way to use this type of
storytelling in a way that points back
to christ man you're putting me on the
spot here um
i would say
i would say it's probably best not to do
that
and it's probably best to stay away from
that and when i say that i actually
don't think that horror movies
can't
bring
someone to
at least
a sensitivity to christ
but i would say that mostly for your own
soul let's say and so right there's a
manner in which even the lowest things
can contain something which
reveals some mystery or some aspect but
you know it's it's kind of like i talked
about the idea of sinning and
opportunity and so it's like
even when you sin
there is a moment of of opportunity
there but i'm not going to tell you to
sin and i think it's the same with
horror movies and so i i think that
to spend so much time as a pr as a
writer as a producer as a as a director
in
a a story of uh
of extreme violence and horror
um
is something that might not be super
good for your for your soul but
i mean i have to be careful
you know i'm not saying there isn't
absolutely a way to do it but i think
that it would be very dangerous and
you know make sure that you have a
of someone you trust a good spiritual
father that could kind of help you
through that if that's something that
you feel that you really have to do so
so harold gonzalez says
as a software engineer who has learned a
lot from your videos i've been thinking
lately about suggestion algorithms
recommendation feeds etc and the often
destructive effect they can have on
human community yeah
as these algorithms develop in
sophistication
can we begin to think about them as
powers and principalities if so
they are some new form of principalities
or are
they
or are they a new digital means of
embodying principalities that already
exist thanks
okay so
let's say suggestion algorithm and
recommendation feeds
uh i would say the best way to
understand them
and i'm gonna say something you guys
something you're gonna think is crazy
oh man all right okay
so i'm still going to do this all right
so the way to understand them
is something like uh
like a trap
for an aspect of you
um
so think about it like
think about it like you have
these potential ways of manifesting
yourself you know
and so
for the suggestion feed to work
it has to connect to you or else it's
not going to work or else you're not
going to follow the suggestion
for it to work it has to be something
which connects
your
will
to that which is you're trying to do now
what's dangerous about it is that
it can frame that it can act like a
it can twist it it can turn it
towards something which is almost
what you would have done but not
completely what you'd have done and so
it becomes a way it comes a very subtle
way
to
control your embodiment would be the
best way to understand it right to
control the way in which you you you you
will embody your logos
um so those things exist
uh they they they exist already in
culture that is
you know we have ways to embody our
intentions that are ritually bound right
so you know when you meet someone you
say hello and there's variability in
there right but they'll probably say
something like how are you doing and
then you answer i'm doing well what
about you you know and there's it
doesn't have to be exactly those words
but there's a there's a framing of the
embodiment right which
happens
in these cultural traditional rituals
right now the difficulty that we have
the difficulty of
of these suggestion algorithms is that
one
they are meticulously invading every
aspect of your
expression right they it's a like it's
on google
on gmail right you write you're you're
writing a sentence and it suggests you
the end of a sentence so it's coming
it's like it's hyper
it's entering in in a very hyper way
into every way you're communicating and
and we also don't trust the people
behind it we also don't trust the
intentions of those that hold the keys
to those algorithms and recommendations
because
you know and so it's like
the the let's say the the process by
which
hello how are you doing i'm doing well
manifested itself is a very ancient
ancient ancient thing that
that just organically
manifested itself to embody your
intentions
but this thing
you know it's owned by a company
companies that have shown that they have
ideological leanings
and so it's super scary
you know
it's scary stuff um
because it's just at the beginning you
know it's like just a very a very subtle
nudging of you towards certain
possibilities and as that gets more
subtle
you're basically going you can be
brainwashed by google and by these
suggestion things
and you can see it like you know
everybody knows right that if you go on
google
uh
and even in terms of algorithms and
stuff right you can go on google and
there's certain things that if you start
to write in google they won't finish for
you because they know where you're going
but they don't want you to go there
uh
and there's certain things that even if
you type it up and you search it they're
not going to show you what you've typed
they're going to show you an ideological
version of that which you put in and so
all this stuff is just just
yeah all right so lynn holland says i
feel like what differs now from previous
patterns of communism is that humanity
is much more mobile
for those in areas where you're deemed
sick until proven healthy does it make
more sense to move to an area where
freedom and human faces are welcome
as opposed to staying in a place where
you approach
your approach to life leaves you facing
scorn so
it's like i agree with you but you have
to understand also
that marx was right in a certain way is
that
mark's theory was that
communism would appear
after
after a form of world capitalism
can only really work
as a kind of world system
and so
as we're kind of moving in this weird
this mobility of people
it's not necessarily going to do what
you think maybe in the short term where
people that are similar to each other
can meet in some places and create
little bastions of of uh
of um
resistance you know it's actually it's
it's actually gonna manifest that
ultimately it's to go probably go the
other way where
this mobility is going to create a need
right for a world pattern and a world
authority and we're already seeing it's
already there my goodness it's like all
these coping measures uh you know
they're already showing us that even if
officially there's no world authority
it's it's all playing out that way so
all right so erie fisher says hi
jonathan i've been very interested in
hearing you speak here and there about
eschatology and i want to see if the
understanding i've pieced together is on
the mark the eschaton is like an eternal
moment where everything that has
occurred in time is revealed in a
simultaneity and also the spiritual
principles behind all occurrences are
revealed thus we'll be able to see the
truth of all things and what principles
our actions were acting as bodies
so even if taking a certain action in
the present wouldn't technically be
the full equivalent of say accepting the
mark of the beast the eschaton would be
revealed to have been participating in
the pattern and thus part of its body am
i confusing some things would this be
more like the last judgment than the
resurrection so i can see i can see what
you what you're getting to i mean i
think that the first part of what you're
saying
um
hey i'm seeing your mate tom is in the
in the chat nice to see you you guys
need to check out the interview i did
with your mate tom by the way one of the
craziest interviews that i've done and
people are really liking it because uh
he really pushed me in a direct in
directions and talking about things in
ways that i haven't before and we ended
up talking about everything you know
aliens ufos uh
you know clockwork elves all that stuff
so so check that out it's hard to
interrupt your question harry um
so i'm really wary about this idea you
know that would be revealed as have been
participating in the pattern and thus
part of the body i think
i think it's it's a dangerous way to
it's a dangerous way to look at it and
it's a it's too much of a technical way
to look at this type of thing and so you
know so let's say this way let me let me
say this way for you to understand that
what you're saying is true to a certain
extent uh but you could say that
all acts of civilization
right from the first city that cain
founded even from the first mark that
cain received through the entire city
through the all the manifestations of
civilization
until
the end
are going to be part of the body
of the beast and so
so if you if you're able to see it that
way then that's fine but if you're if
you're trying to use this
to to uh
to decide whether or not what's going on
right now is the mark of the beast i
think that that your logic is not going
to uh
is not going to totally hold
um
so el dorado says i remember you talking
about making a video on attack on titan
are you waiting for the show to end also
what is the symbolism of elon musk
i just haven't watched the whole show
it's like i don't you know
yeah i don't uh i don't watch a lot of
it i think i haven't watched an episode
in months now and so yeah it's just
because i don't watch it i've been
watching a few more movies and before
like i watched a green night i ended up
watching uh
um
the this hidden the this hidden life by
terence malik which i thought was really
beautiful and amazing and thanks for all
of you that have suggested that i watch
it but um
but i haven't finished uh attack on
titan so you know
yeah um
all right so anders ralstad hi jonathan
what is the symbolism of loud church
bells heard from far away
is there an order to win their ring
should ring yes of course there's an
order they'd never ring a church belt
never ring randomly at least they
shouldn't if they do it's silly you know
they ring to mark something and so
that's what it has to do with it has to
do with memory and has to do with
hearing let's say the music from far
away so that you remember that you're
connected to that and so
church bells ring uh in a in a catholic
setting they'll ring when there are
services they'll ring at a certain time
but those certain times are not just
times they're prayers right people do
the angelus at 12 they they used to they
would hear the church bells ring and
then they would stop what they're doing
and they would pray the angelus and
there are different moments in the day
where the church belt would ring and
then people would do
certain prayers uh and they also mark
events right like marriages and deaths
and and uh people that are important in
the community um so that you know we
have this
this connection even if it's somewhat
unconsciously to the center of our of
our community
right amy hi jonathan would you be able
to expand on the back and forth you had
with john vervice on twitter the other
day about kenosis and totality is the
kinetic kinetic fullness in christ story
the key apologetic for christianity
above other religions and is looking for
an intellectual reason for certainty a
trap form of idolatry when it comes to
faith thanks um and so i don't know if
it's necessarily the
apologetic for christianity but it's
definitely
uh it's definitely that which
christianity is showing in a kind of
fullness with the cross
um and it's interesting because when i
did it when i talked about it with john
which is basically the idea that as you
reach identity you know
the highest aspect of identity is
sacrifice it's actually sacrifice of
identity so the ultimate the highest
part of identity is negation of identity
so you can imagine
there's a kind of breakdown of identity
at the bottom
where you lose your identity in
dispersion and fragmentation and chaos
but there's a kind of negation of
identity which happens at the top which
is you giving yourself up
to that which is above you
uh and then also giving yourself down
to that which is below and so i think
that that really is the ultimate pattern
that's why if you look at my image of
the image of everything that's why the
cross is in the holy of holies right
that's why the cross is the tree of life
uh that's the mystery right um
and so um so i'm gonna talk about this a
little more like the next video i have
is gonna talk a little bit about that in
terms of kind of apophatic and
cataphatic and also i talk about it in
this
video i did for the jung society which
jordan peterson will be putting up on
his channel so if you're interested in
that you'll have more
of that and it and it's interesting i
mean it's important that i talk about it
more as people kind of get to understand
the pattern because it's
there is a danger in thinking of these
identities as solid right of these of a
chair as a solid thing that like totally
exists in the world and it only exists
to the extent that it gives itself to us
right it doesn't exist in itself and we
only exist to the extent that we give
ourselves to that which is above us you
know and so you can say the chair
sacrifices itself
to us
and then we sacrifice ourselves to to
god you know uh
anyways so
hey
we'll we'll you'll see more of this in
the next in the next few months
all right kent and hari says on the
surface it seems like you and father
andrew stephen demick are doing
something quite different where you're
indicating patterns which are supposed
to be observable at every level
experience seems to me that he's trying
to recover a particular narrative as it
was understood in a particular space and
time can you share some reflection on
what you see as the overlap and so
i think the difference between what
father andrew
and father stephen are doing in the lord
of spirits and the different endeavors
they're doing
is they're trying to really recover this
the pattern and the story from the
inside you know i kind of play both
sides you know i
i tell people that you have to be inside
the pattern that you have to be inside
the story but then i still
play a game
where i explain it
and then i try to go back in and then i
explain it and i try to go back in
and there's something about that which
is useful but there's something about
that which is also
um
a consequence of the breakdown of
meaning whereas what father andrew is
doing is just saying you are in this
story right you're in the same story as
enoch you have to deal with demons and
you have to deal with angels and you
have to deal with all this stuff um
and that's actually the first place more
than the kind of
desire to explicate the patterns at
every level of reality but i think that
andrew father andrew does think that you
know but he's actually trying to embody
it more also because he's he's a priest
and father stephen a priest and so they
that's their job right to embody it in
the world through the sacraments and
through
um you know through their pastoral work
so
um and so jan peter jagger is the middle
between opposites always a paradox
um and so
i mean not necessarily you know it can
be
it especially
in the in the sense of christ but it can
all it's it can just be a it's a
resolution right it's just it can also
be just a resolution of opposites
um
but that's interesting right because
there is an aspect which is paradoxical
and there's an aspect of it which is
solid
and so that might have something to do
with
what i talked about in terms of
some of the aspects of the mystery of
christ right you know
the king and the sacrifice you know
something like that
all right
all right isaac says how symbolism can
give to our pity lives at least some
meaning how can we participate in that
meeting
go to church dude
sorry
go to church is the best way just is the
best way to say it you know at least as
an at the outset it'll play itself out
in other aspects of your world you know
sit around the table with your family
have a meal together you know uh
take the social rituals we have and that
have been handed to us seriously don't
see them as arbitrary you know don't
don't engage with them as if they're
arbitrary uh
etc
all right so um
ali says
says
what is the symbolism of fear is it
related to being possessed
by a demonic entity most times we don't
take risks because of fear and allow
that to hold us back thank you
uh merci
um
and so there's a good part there's a
good aspect of fear and there's a
there's a bad aspect of fear
um
so think about it in the garden
where
after
adam and eve uh
you know after adam and eve ate the
fruit and they they covered themselves
and then they they were afraid
and they hid themselves out of fear and
out of shame
um
and then it also says that you know fear
of the lord is the beginning of wisdom
and so
this is it's a mysterious
aspect because there's an aspect of fear
which is a kind of awe
you know which makes you want to
which makes you want to
not improperly address
let's say engage with the thing in front
of you think of it that way not
improperly address it because
you feel like you're not in control of
it you know so that's the sense in which
fear can be good in terms of god
but it can also be paralyzing because
um
because it yeah it just
stops you and it separates you from
from others as well
and so you can understand it like an
interesting like an interesting way to
see it would be to you know all these
stories of how
the angel or christ himself right christ
himself coming down the mountain you
know walking on the waters and then the
disciples are afraid
uh
and then christ says
uh do not fear
or you know gabriel presenting himself
to to the mother of god you know and
then do not be afraid right the angel
that said do not be afraid and so that
there's something in there
um
but yeah yeah
so i can also kind of feel like i'm
getting tired i'm happy that i stopped
the the uh
i'm happy that i stopped the the super
chat this month sorry guys for those who
were counting on that
um chandler says what is the symbolism
of the so-called anti-hero this is a
trope you see all over the place in
contemporary culture and i see it being
praised as more realistic than the
standard hero also recently discovered
how hybrids might be implicated in the
origin of the pandemic in the form of
humanized mice
all right so dude those two things have
nothing to do with each other like i
thought this was one thing all right so
i'm not going to deal with the humanized
mice thing
um
then i see it being praised as more
realistic than the standard hero and so
it would make sense because we live in
an upside down world you know the
anti-hero
uh
as this this kind of this flip side to
to the heroes willing to sacrifice
himself you know the selfish character
the but if you look at the stories of
anti-heroes that
if you look at stories of anti-heroes
that succeed that are good stories of
anti-heroes that the ones that people
really like are always the story
of the person who is selfish
self-absorbed and is all and is uh out
of control he's a drunk he's a womanizer
he's all these things but then despite
himself maybe
he ends up doing the right thing you
know that's the story of the anti-hero
that that connects with people
and it's interesting because it's
actually the pattern of the anti-hero
itself which is that in manifesting the
upside down
of heroism it's a it's also the pattern
of antichrist it's like in manifesting
the upside down of christ and the
opposite of christ there secretly
without even knowing it without even
realizing it
they're secretly pointing us back to the
real hero and pointing us back to
christ because we recognize the
anti-hero as exactly that as an
anti-hero and so the hero always is the
reference
and it's the same with antichrist you
know
it christ will always be the reference
of antichrist and a hero would always be
the the
will always be the reference of uh
christ and so that's why it plays that
that out that way in the successful
versions of the stories and it's it's
the
it's the symbolism of the anti-hero
itself all right
all right so shane mccoosker says hey
jonathan i was wondering if you could
help me make sense of the role that the
protestant church might play in the
narrative of god's church
is often portrayed as a place for the
unchurched over church and de-churched
however these accommodations make me
feel uneasy i'm a protestant for what
that is worth
thanks for your time and thank god for
your symbolic gift um
yeah so i mean i think that
i don't want to i don't want to justify
let's say what happened in the in the
the the breakdown of of protestantism
but i think that there's a mystery in
that as well and i've talked about that
that also i think we even talked about
it today which is that there's a mystery
in this fire this breakdown
you could say
uh and so the separation of the churches
which are a scandal nonetheless but end
up filling up every little nook and
cranny of reality
uh and
and so despite even themselves end up
bringing christ into the
the ends of the earth uh but also
diluting like the waters of paradise
right they get further and further away
deluding the message as they split and
deluding
the fullness of
of the mystical part the the ontological
the cosmic aspect of christianity
deluding it as they move out but
nonetheless moving out and nonetheless
filling reality
uh
so
and then i think there'll be a surprise
in the end there'll be a surprise where
all of this is going to
you know somehow
come together right i don't know how and
i don't you know i'm i'm
i'm not i'm not an ecumenist in the in
the basics like in the vulgar sense of
that i don't think people should just
forget the divisions and pretend and
just come together and in kumbaya you
know but but i do think that nonetheless
there's going to be a surprise and
there's going to be a
way in which this is going to play out
uh like just like in the story of
just like in every time christ acts this
transformation of scandal into
into uh into glory somehow
all right so joe kelly o'neil says hey
jonathan i'm about 150 pages into the
ethics of beauty it's confirming a new
way that i should pursue beauty first it
hasn't defined beauty or the sub aspects
of beauty in a way i understand quite
yet what should i read to understand the
aspects of beauty better and especially
in an orthodox way
in order to know what to aim at put
simpler how should i define beauty
and so
think of beauty as
of them think of beauty as the pattern
okay
but the pattern in the way in which it
draws things together
so it's important to understand that
when i talk about patterns it's that
patterns
draws multiplicity into itself
and so there's something
there's something about the pattern
which is which is which could be said to
be something like erotic that is the
pattern
calls being
into
its pattern
and so
that is
the that is beauty and so you could say
that this it's like this this calling
into and this drawing together
and then it's in this drawing together
so think of it
so the multiplicity gets drawn together
by the beauty by this this this
the seductive pattern that that brings
you together
that's the only way that you can then
see the truth of that
pattern
but the first reaction we have to it is
is a kind of attraction it's a kind of
being pulled
that's the best way to explain that um
and so uh timothy for petitions has a
wonderful way of describing that you
know basically saying
beauty first then truth
you know
uh
and it's like beauty towards the good
and then truth
so beauty draws you towards the good so
think think about it think about it as
right the the the beauty of the pattern
of the chair right draws
draws its elements into it through us
but also draws us
to it to sit on it right
and then if you sit on it and you're
drawn into that pattern like you you see
the good
but then ultimately that can lead you to
the talos like you can then see the
reason for the chair but the process
happens
kind of intuitively and more
i don't know i mean i hope i'm making
sense here i feel like during this whole
q a i've been saying things that are way
more difficult than usual sorry sorry if
that's happening guys i hope not i hope
i'm not me and not being uh too esoteric
in this thing
i tried to be as grounded as possible
when i say things so
all right so scotty thorpe says
um how familiar are you with chris
gabriel of meme analysis what are your
thoughts about his content would you be
willing to make a video with him um i
don't know i'm not i'm actually not very
familiar with him at all
i think i maybe have seen a video by him
but uh
but yeah i don't i don't i don't know
him very much i'd have to check out his
channel
um stephen bishop says hi jonathan at
the wedding of kanna what is the
significance of there being seven jars
of water is this related to the margin
777
um also does it connect with to the
symbolism of fermentation
and change mentioned in matthew's book
yeah dude
you pretty hear that not good i mean i
know about the 777 but
is this an image of christ filling
renewing the hierarchy as he begins his
ministry and so it is an image of death
and
death in the sense of moving into
fermentation fermentation is controlled
death right fermentation is a form of
sabbath it's a form of rest it's a form
of death turning against itself
so christ turning water into wine it's
basically starting with the beginning of
genesis and then moving all the way to
the end of his
the the
the highest point you know of of this
of death moving down into into death
itself but
you know transforming it you could say
into
the celebration of the making showing us
that that's the meeting of heaven and
earth what it brings about right the the
wedding feast
is about filling all of this
with the logos um and so yeah man that
that that story is just
has so much and the seven obviously has
to do with the seven days of of creation
itself right so you have the waters at
the beginning and then you have the the
whole you have this idea that the whole
process of creation
uh
and then you have wine and so like i'm
gonna say something that's gonna sound
totally crazy to you guys but some
people people who have listened
to my to my uh to my talk i would
understand it so you can imagine that
you know something like the first jar of
water is would be filled with you know
extremes and then the second jar of
water it would kind of move
uh towards six and the six jar of water
would be
it would be the balance and then the
seventh jar of water would be the wine
so
something like that
but obviously that's not exactly what
that's not what the text says but if you
understand symbolism you'll see what i'm
talking about
all right okay
so do you think non-believing people so
matthew asks do you think non-believing
people utter the words
uh
jesus christ or
my god in response to something as an
inner testament to what they claim to
not believe do you think it's just a
matter of people picking up the
expressions of judah christian culture
they grew up in so you should look it up
i've already talked about this i talked
about it in the last q a the symbolism
of uh blas blaspheming the symbolism of
swearing so check it out there's
actually a clip on the clip channel you
can find a clip of that
um all right and so i'm gonna go there's
one question on subscribe star if my
memory serves me
correctly
um
all right uh one question on the scribe
scar so big lasagna asks
why did the symbol of the christian
night fall somewhat out of fashion the
don quixote it already parodied the idea
of it yeah do you have an idea when it
did start and why so yes your your
intuition about don quixote is exactly
you're exactly right so don quixote
manifests
don quixote is the beginning of the
modern world guys don quixote is
the beginning of
the impossibility of embodying ideals
and how the note it's it's like
nominalism in a story is don quixote and
the idea that
the desire to embody ideals uh you know
leads you to madness leads you to
uh impossibility and so don quixote is
all about the impossibility of something
like the incarnation but it's very it's
at the beginning of that process it's at
the beginning of these ideas but that's
ultimately
what don quixote kind of sets the stage
for you know um and so by the time that
don quixote appears
the ideal of the christian night and the
notion of
embodying ideals in the world itself was
already on the out and out and it's also
about desacralization don quixote it's
also about
um
disenchantment right and so
you realize that the giants are just a
bunch of windmills dude you know
are you don't you understand that it's
not giants don't exist right santa claus
doesn't exist it's all a guy it's just a
guy in a red suit people
and so this is this is what you're
seeing um
you know
and
how can i say this
people had understood
that those win there's something in
those windmills of the giants
back in the time of don quixote
if people had been wise enough to
understand that then
then maybe we wouldn't have something as
insane as in artificial intelligence
today
and so
i'm sure cervantes does even know
doesn't even know that don quixote was
right
in a symbolic sense
so that's my take on that all right
uh so so let me set let me check it out
i said i was going to do the uh the
super chats uh
and uh
so we're gonna do the super chat
logan williams in the chat says sheesh
this dunk yody truth bombs are making me
real sad
oh man yeah don quixote blackpill is
what i drop you know that's my job is to
just
sorry guys
um
okay
so uh all right so let's see so let's
see so so so wow this new guy there
there's there's like so many questions
in the super chats by the new guy
so the new guy uh for 499 most of the
time and then 9.99 for one of these
questions says
um what would you say to someone who
says praying to the saints is idolatry
heresy where does scripture validate
this practice thanks for all you do
and so i would say that that
that uh the saints tell us to pray for
each other all the time and that that
since this since in christ we are we are
alive we are not dead uh in that there
is only one body there are two bodies
there isn't like one body that's out
there and one body that is in here there
is one god one one
one son one
church one body
and we all pray for each other in that
body and just like asking for your
pastor or your friend to pray for you
in the same way
we ask for the saints to pray for us
so the new guy again he says why does
richard rowland say that wichita is the
fourth rome is this an inside joke
uh and he's saying that because seven
with his eighth day oh i'm gonna get
eight day books is there and he loves
eight day books and because it's a it's
a wonderful like uh it's a wonderful uh
uh
bookstore and publishing that is kind of
a
kind of bastion for classical thinking
and literature and all of that and so
that's why he says that you know
so um
so the new guy for 999 says again what
in your eyes would be the best depiction
of a christian warrior especially the
one who suffers from
past sin i'm an aspiring author and i
want to perfect this idea
does solomon cain come to mind
so a christian warrior who suffers from
past sin
i don't know about the suffering from
past sin i mean except for gawain
himself you know you see that in the
story of gawain um
you see it also in lancelot like
lancelot is uh
like a very
high christian warrior who suffers
uh
who suffers interiorly and then
ultimately also
uh becomes a
stumbling stone you know for the for the
because he he
has an affair with uh arthur's wife with
gwenevere
and it ends with him joining a monastery
so you know so maybe those are good two
good examples of
christian words who suffer from sin
all right and so 499 if we're all a part
of saintly priesthood why pray to only
certain saints if we are all saints what
warrants their elevation over the rest
of us and the answer is hierarchy
i mean there's just a hierarchy
you know and so
you
it's the same like that question right
is the same idea that you know that that
that certain uh branches of the of
christianity will say things like
you know it says in scripture that we're
a nation of priests and so we shouldn't
have any priests
and it's just
and it's the same people who say
something like
uh
it says in scripture that in christ
there's neither man or woman so we
shouldn't have men male priests and we
should not have gender roles and it's
just people who don't understand
hierarchy they just don't understand
hierarchy what can i tell you
and so you know
when it says that we're a nation and
priest in scripture it said that in the
old testament too you know it said that
israel were a nation of priests but not
everybody in israel was a priest
you know israel acted like
the people of israel acted like priests
of the world and then within israel
fractals like pattern
priests acted upon them
and so and then in god
all these distinctions go away you know
all of these decisions the hierarchy is
not for god right the hierarchy is for
us in in the lower aspects of the
hierarchy and so
for the same reason that you would pray
you would the same reason if you saw
someone who was close to that you would
okay for the same reason that you would
ask
your friend in church to pray for you
and you wouldn't ask nicki minaj to pray
for you
is the same reason that you would then
also ask the pastor to pray for you
maybe more you might also ask a saint to
pray for you even more
because they have shown that they embody
christ at different levels
of the hierarchy so of a hierarchy of
participation in the life of god so
hopefully that makes sense dude
all right so tao lombarda last one five
say d if we escape the tyranny that we
are headed towards are you optimistic
for a mass self-reflection
of what happened or what will fill the
vacuum after
and so
sorry to blackfill you guys we're not
we're not escaping the oncoming tyranny
so i don't know what to tell you
it's gonna get worse before it gets
better guys
sorry
all right and so so yeah so i think i
think we're done guys and uh
yeah so i think we're gonna continue
with the no super chats people just
because
just because just because i think this
is about as much as i can handle we'll
see like uh and and also
i'll try to we'll also try to eliminate
the questions that are asked there are
some questions that are almost that are
asked almost at every super every q a
which i get it i mean not everybody
watches all the q and a's but you know
um maybe also if you have a question go
to the clips channel subscribe to the
clips channel and check out on the clips
channel if that that question has
already been answered because the uh
the the
the
the cliff channel will often take one
question in this in the uh
in the q a one that has been important
or comes up a lot
and then we'll just have a video of that
and so that might help to avoid these
repetitions so
um
all right guys so thanks you for thank
you for your attention and uh thanks to
people who uh who uh
who um are supporting me as well all the
patrons
and uh and uh yeah so check out what's
coming like this this
video on the jordan peterson these two
videos that are coming out and george
peters's channel are pretty exciting and
uh as you've seen i'm kind of ramping up
the amount of videos that i'm putting
out a every month um i
the as you've noticed if you're on if
you're supporting me you've noticed that
there hasn't been a supporter only video
yet this month and it's the last day but
it will be there tomorrow i hope and if
not tomorrow then uh then on monday and
so apologies for that but it's coming i
will not i will not give you and uh and
uh you will have a patron-only video
this month so thanks for everybody and
uh and i appreciate your your attention
and i wish you the best in these dark
times and i would say you know something
i i know that i i know that i
a lot of the questions kind of forced me
to go into uh into the dark places but
there's a lot of hope as well and the
hope comes out of the darkness you know
i the more i hear about what's going
like i'm hearing all these these
chatting all these rumors of catechumens
appearing in the orthodox churches so i
don't know what's going on in the in the
other in the in the other churches in
the catholic church or in the protestant
church but at least in america and the
orthodox churches there's a lot of noise
about how
this year there are more catechumens
than they have ever seen and so
these these difficulties that we're
going through are going to wake up a lot
of people to what's happening and to the
acceleration of the meaning crisis
uh and though it's going to be painful
no doubt you know
i like myself
so
two days ago or was it yesterday
yesterday evening i went
uh to uh to celebrate readers only
vespers at a uh at a new friend of
mine's uh place he is himself as a
catechumen coming from byzantine
catholicism
and i was there we had ten young
there was there was one there's one
woman and nine
there's like i guess i was there too so
actually count myself so eight young men
most of them catechumen a few of them
had been baptized who wanted to learn
to do vespers at home and to kind of to
to also commune together and eat
together and uh and exchange and so i
think
those little things that they're not
much they kind of they give me hope and
so so uh so don't lose hope guys you
know there's uh there's light on the end
of the tunnel it's but there's a dark
tunnel before it so so thanks everybody
for attention and uh and i'll see you
very soon bye-bye